thomas campbell is the author of my big
toe
that is my big theory of everything and
is a former nuclear physicist
he's also one of the most requested
guests of this channel
recalling that this channel is dedicated
to explicating on theories of everything
keep in mind that he calls it a big toe
as opposed to a small toe because he
makes the delineation that a big toe is
supposed to be responsible for the
fundamental laws of physics
an explanation as to what consciousness
is or how consciousness arises
how should we interact with one another
why are we here what is god is there a
god etc
as opposed to a small toe which he
describes as being strictly about the
fundamental laws of physics in
mathematical form
like the donald hoffman interview this
is likely the most
technical interview that you'll see with
thomas campbell and that's because i
think only asking simple questions that
let's say a layman can understand you
necessarily give the wrong impression
because you distort the truth in the
simplification
if you'll allow me a two-minute aside
i'll explain or you can just click the
timestamp and skip ahead straight to the
interview
i have a mini rant about being taught
that the wave function is a function
when it's not and i'm not talking about
qft or even quantum gravity i'm talking
about simple quantum mechanics you're
taught it's a function but it's not the
wave function is technically a smooth
section which is completely different
than a function
you'll get into trouble if you think of
it as a function a smooth section on a
complex line bundle
with a base manifold and that's not
incorporating relativity has nothing to
do with relativity and you need this in
order to do quantum mechanics on simple
curved surfaces like a sphere
another example where the simplification
or the imprecise idea
being conveyed is simply wrong is that
the wave function is a square integrable
member
of a hilbert space it's not and you know
this because
if you just use the momentum operator on
a box function well it's not defined
right at the edges even though it's
square integrable and that's a simple
function
these are examples where i was told the
simplified truth or the imprecise truth
but it fails in elementary cases and it
leads to unnecessary
headaches therefore i keep the level of
precision in these podcasts as high as i
possibly can
because you're extremely bright and
motivated
no one is telling you to watch this
you're watching this of your own
volition your open
your astute streamlining and simplifying
is done on many
channels there's nothing wrong with that
you can go to lex friedman or joe rogan
for that if you like
it's just that it's a saturated market
and i'm wholly
uninterested the ramifications at least
for me
of simplifying is worse than intricacy
but mainly there's also the aspect that
the audience that is you
seem to be more engaged extremely
engaged when i'm engaged that is that i
actually want to know the answers to the
questions i'm asking
i'm not asking well what are your top
three favorite books what inspires you
i don't care about that i want to know
what is the relationship between
the paranormal psy and jung
synchronicity thomas why do you define
consciousness as that which has
evolutionary potential
why do you call life a turing machine
when it seems pretty clear that there's
a physical trade-off between structure
function complexity and
genomic length which doesn't
characterize a turing machine's tape
either way you get the idea you're here
to listen to thomas campbell
let's get started enjoy tom why don't
you tell the audience what you're
working on these days
okay um
well i suspect what you're referring to
working on these days is
uh the my big toe since you are
obviously interested in theories of
everything
that's one of your subjects of interest
um my big toe
uh was called my not because i'm so
proud of it
it's because if it's not your experience
then it can't be your truth so my big
toe is basically
based on my experience my research
and my conclusions and
my big toe should just be perhaps a
structure or a platform for
each person to build their own big top
it's it's not something to be believed
belief is is a problem belief gets in
the way where you have a belief
you put yourself what behind a wall
you don't then let in other information
that conflicts with that belief
so beliefs are always a problem to
you know to understanding you know the
big picture
so i would not encourage anybody to
believe my model but to
look at it and see if it applies to
their
life so i'm a physicist let's just give
you a little overview at you know my big
toe it's a it's a model of everything
it's a big toe not just a toe mostly
when you hear about toes
they're not really about everything
they're a theory of
physics there's a very they're a theory
of
fundamental science within this universe
you know the science of our universe
that's what they are
and what they leave out
is everything that is subjective in
other words
consciousness you know attitudes
feelings
emotions
everything that's in the
subjective world and if you think about
it
most of our world that is important to
us
does fall in this subjective side the
objective world
of physicists and i'm a physicist but
the objective world of physics
is basically just a subset of the world
that we live in
and interact in and it's i would say
a minor subset it's the it's the stage
it's the props
it's all the stuff um
important things in our life like who
should i marry
should i take this job or that job you
know uh
that sort of thing big things that
change our lives change our thinking now
what book should i read
all of these choices are not objective
choices
they're all subjective choices so most
of our
more meaningful experiences like love
you know
justice truth all these things are
subjective
you know you know or at least have large
components
of subjectiveness in them so
a theory of everything has to also be a
theory of the subjective world
as well as the objective world otherwise
you've just got a little tao
which is just the theory of the
objective world so mai tai was a bit
different
and mine started with
or i should say mine starts with
consciousness as a fundamental
and the reason that i came to that is
that i was in graduate school in physics
working on my phd in experimental
nuclear
physics and
i found out just quite by accident that
i could debug my
my computer code now back in those days
this is the old days in computer code
i'm talking about boxes of cards you
know that sort of thing
and debugging was a huge problem
not like the day where you have
debuggers and instant terminals and
access
to you know to the computers and so on
and those days
there was a big central computer and it
took up a whole building
and it was not as powerful as your
telephone is today
it was probably only a hundredth or a
thousandth as powerful as your cell
phone is today
and the whole school the whole
university
ran on that one computer there were no
there were no
desktops so you've got to stand in line
in a queue
and if you got one or two jobs run a
week
well lucky you so if that job
ran because and bombed because you had
an error
well you just lost a week for your
research you see so
debugging was something people spent a
lot of time
focused on so that they didn't have to
wait forever to get their
their research done and their and their
their ideas
worked out so in any case i found that
in my mind
i could bring up a picture in a
meditation state i learned to meditate
while i was in graduate school
and i learned because the advertisement
said that you could get by with less
sleep
and in graduate school that just was
was a real big plus for me so that's why
i
learned how to meditate and anyway in
this meditation state i could bring up a
picture
of my output my printout scroll through
all the lines in code
and the lines that had errors in them
had problems in them would just show up
red
that was an intention of mine i wanted
to be able to see them and i just did
this kind of on a wild hair you know
kind of a
lark well i'm in a meditation state
let's see what i can do
and i checked it out and it was correct
those lines of code were
actually the ones that had problems and
in these days a problem wasn't because
necessarily you
it incorrectly maybe the the key punch
was just off a hair
if those little holes didn't line up
exactly right with the reader
you'd get an error you know so you may
have done all the right things but the
machine
was a little off that punched holes so
that as a physicist that hit me like
with a like a ton of bricks uh what was
going on here how could i
do that there was no physical process
going on it was entirely a mental
process and how could my mental process
find things like key punch errors
you know that's was just crazy
so i played with it and i played with it
and i found that i got better with it
with practice
and that i could decode my stuff very
i mean you know debug it very very
quickly
so as a physicist what that told me was
that my
my idea that reality
is measurable if it's not measurable
in other words this is called a um
what's the word for the uh it's like if
you can't interact with it
you know if you're talking about
something you say oh this is real but
you can't interact with it you can't see
it can't
operationalism yeah it's an operational
definition
of reality exactly so i
as a physicist that was my attitude
toward reality it's
it's an operational reality so
i realized that wasn't true that there
was more to reality
than just what you could measure what
you could do operations on
it had another whole component to it
that was more tied up to mental
than to physical it was subjective
not objective so i just
kind of had that as an idea wow i'd like
to find out more about this because
as a physicist my job was to model
reality to understand how reality works
and i realized there was this whole big
piece of reality
that was outside of what i had thought
was possible
so i just walked around with that i
didn't really know what to do about it
or how to
deal with it other than it was there
and it wasn't a matter of did i just
imagine that
that was ridiculous of course i didn't
imagine i can't imagine that oh this
whole
you know is one hundredth of a
millimeter you know too far to the right
that's not something you can imagine so
in any case when i got out of graduate
school took a job
and as you know luck would have it
about probably four five six months into
my first
job as a physicist i
was nuclear physicist correct yeah
nuclear
um not high energy nuclear but low
energy nuclear
we worked with a big van de graaff
accelerator so
you know 5 mev was about as far as we
could go as far as
energy went so anyway
i was introduced to bob monroe i got to
meet
bob monroe now bob monroe had written
books called journey out of the body
and at that time and i read that book
and
my opinion of it was well if this is
probably just trying to sell books you
know this guy's writing making up a
story
is an interesting story but he's just
making it up and he's just and you read
this
book after your transcendental
meditation sessions
no i read this like three
years after i become you know
about three years after uh i learned how
to do meditation
it was a long time i got a job and
actually it was my boss
tossed me into this group by bob monroe
and said read this book
and i read it just read it because you
got to be kidding
journeys out of the body boss really
but i read it and i told him you know
he's either making it up
to get money or it's indicative of
another
piece of reality that we just don't know
about
but how can we tell is he for real or is
he
is he not because at that point i was
open to reality being bigger than just a
physical because of my experiences some
three years ago you know in graduate
school being able to debug code
so i was open-minded to perhaps there's
more
and the more is in mental space you know
in mind space
not in physical space so we went out
just to get some acronyms out of the way
there's pmr which is physical matter
reality right
and then there's npmr is which is
non-physical matter
reality right okay okay yeah and
basically there's that definition is
that pmr
is what we call our physical universe
it's what we call physical
okay and that the npmr
is everything else anything else so when
you dream
you're not the reality in your dream is
in nvmr
it's not part of the physical world so
it's just terminology that lets
me differentiate the physical world from
everything else
so anyway my boss
found out where bob monroe lived it
wasn't that far from where we worked
and we made an appointment to go see him
and i did and he was a very
wealthy guy he didn't need book sales he
was way
past the money that book sales bring in
and he was
he had a personality like an engineer he
was very you know he was bright but very
factual
you know very very clear he wasn't fuzzy
headed
and kind of on the on the crazy side
and he told us that he'd just built a
lab
to study consciousness because he wanted
to bring
science to this experience of his so he
wanted to study it and he was looking
for some scientists that would help him
study so i
shot my hand up in the air you know i've
been a student like for 30 years yes i
put my hand up in the air right away and
about a month or so later i was making
trips
you know every week you know out to the
lab
and starting to actually first we had to
build equipment in the lab we built the
equipment with eeg we built the gsrs and
other things to
what are gsrs that's a galvanic skin
response
it basically measures skin resistivity
you know the resistance of your skin to
a
very small electrical dc current and
that changes based on mind state if you
relax or meditate that resistance goes
up if you're very excited it goes down
you know like a neurophysiological
measurement yeah
it's something that tells you a little
bit about something of mine we didn't
you know we were trying to
measure whatever we could and there's
not a lot that measures
things that are primarily mental you
know so eeg and gsr were two of the
things that we could do and we could
afford so we
we built most of the equipment we wired
the lab
we we uh kind of set things up and then
we got in the booths and bob would come
up
and teach us what he knew about
observing and interacting with this
larger reality which is
outside this physical universe
in other words mind space and of course
myself
and an electrical engineer came with me
we said we were both in this together we
both worked at the same
place and our idea was well if this
turns out to be a lot of hocus pocus you
know we're out of here but
if it turns out that we really learned
something then great we were both
excited about the possibilities of of
learning something so the deal was that
we'd help bob
and we would be free we wouldn't cost
him anything
and and that he would teach us so we
could experience it because if we just
examined him
well you know you can if you learn about
something that you study but you've
never experienced
it's never quite real we wanted to
experience it so we could find it out
for ourselves
or you know how real it was made it more
objective for us
even though it was still in a subjective
space so he did
every you know we came out there a
couple of days a week
and he tried to teach us to experience
mental space things in mental space and
what dennis and i wanted to do is let's
prove that this is real
to ourselves not just something we're
imagining not just something we're
making up but
is it real so we started doing
things that were evidential
um you know like remote viewing things
are very evidential
you know we go in get in our booths and
the booths we had were isolation booths
they all were
uh um acoustically isolated from each
other and one of them was a faraday cage
which was electromagnetic oh
great i was going to ask you about that
yeah one was a faraday cage that's the
one i got in was the faraday cage and
one dennis there was actually three
booths in a row
i got in number one dennis got number
three so there was an empty one between
us
so the acoustical isolation was was even
greater than
than it would be for two consecutive
booths but so we did we got in these
booths
and there's a microphone coming down
from the ceiling just above our lips
and bob would help us get into the
mental state
and gave us exercises and things to do
and we would tell him what we were
experiencing
and that way he could be more effective
in guiding us
but bob was very careful about not
leading the witness you know he wasn't
saying well now you should see this
he would never say that because that's
leading people to say something
he would just say do this and this and
this now what do you see
and so we did this and we pride
evidential things
remote viewing is one of the obvious
ones and we did other things too
we did you know mental healing and we
did
uh collecting
data trying to get information from
however we could get information mental
healing of who of yourself or of someone
else
of other people of other people that we
knew about who had illnesses
we did we did that but you have to do
that hundreds of times
to collect statistics on whether or not
you're having an effect you know you
don't know
somebody could just get better and may
not have anything to do with
what you did but we would work on people
sometimes that had chronic things they'd
been
they'd had this chronic illness for you
know three decades 30 years
and they were outside of the medical
system because the medical system had
said there's nothing else we can do
and we would try to see if we could fix
things like that so that's more
evidential than just though somebody has
a headache
oh my headache went away well it might
have gone away anyway you know so you
have to have
you have to look at these things
carefully but dennis and i were both
being very careful because we were both
very skeptical
so bob did teach us and right just as an
aside you mentioned that
npmr isn't scientific but it sounds like
what you're saying is pmr
that is our physical reality can
interact with mind space or npmr and
then
npmr can interact with us so you have
transitivity which means that you can
have objective measures no yes you can
have some that's what i mean by
evidential things so
these were the things these interactions
say we could remote view
we could see what was going on at a
particular place we'd go get in our
booths and bob would go into another
room
and he'd write a you know like a five or
six seven digit number you know on the
blackboard
that he had in there and our job would
be to to read it
and in a sense we didn't do that in the
sense of
remote viewing we did that from the
sense of going out of body going into
that room and looking at the blackboard
what's the difference between remote
viewing and out of body almost
nothing the the belief of the person
that's doing it that's
uh that's the only difference the
function
they're really not any different it's
just the way you believe
that the mechanism works these were back
in the early days and
what's the difference in belief between
remote viewing and out of body
well if you believe that you're remote
viewing then basically you
are basically your vision okay
it's like you're tapping into a camera
that's there yeah
okay i understand your vision is
remotely going someplace else that's why
remote viewing so you are
viewing remotely so it's like you can
your eyeballs are someplace else or you
have a camera
someplace else versus some
representation of your body or your soul
right so okay and neither one of those
are true
of course you're not moving you're
you're not moving your vision someplace
and you're you don't have some essence
of your body going anywhere all of those
are just beliefs
none of that works that way but these
are things that people believed and at
that time early on i didn't understand
the nature of reality
well that was my mission to try to
understand it
so we had these models you know out of
body and remote viewing
and things but it turns out that all of
that was kind of
based in belief anyway that's not the
structure of how it really works
so we would do these things that were
evidential and by the evidential things
you know it was probably one in ten
thousand or one in a hundred thousand
that that we were just lucky at guessing
numbers written on boards or that we
were just
you know uh somehow lucky that people
who had been ill for 30 years got better
you know these kinds of things you know
you do statistical significant studies
and the statistical significance has to
tell you basically how far away are you
from
from random occurrences you know it's
random or
how how much distance is it away from
random and we were
very distant from random so we knew
intellectually that we actually were
doing something
we were able to interact with this
reality through line space
through mental space and that was a
gee whiz how does it work why does it
work
what can you do with it why does it
sometimes work and sometimes not work
so well you know why is it not as as
repeatable as we'd like it to be
what does it have to do with mental
state if you're in different kind of
mental states it works
better in this one and not so well in
that one and what's the difference
so the whole point was for me to
understand it
and give some kind of fundamental model
of what was going on how it was going on
produce
a theory that allowed
me to predict results
and methods and explain things like why
this worked and why that didn't work
and so on to understand it so i worked
on that i was the physicist then that
was my job
and that took me about 35 years before
i thought i understood it well enough
because i had to do a lot of research
you know if you if you do remote viewing
and you do it from this mental state and
it doesn't work
then is that just circumstance or is
there really something about that mental
state
or 35 years meaning you were 35 years
old or 35 years from the point that you
started
35 years from the point i started it
took me that long because
science is tedious you have to change
variables and see what happens and then
change the variable a little more and
see what happens and then
change a different variable and see what
happens so
trying to have a scientific approach to
this
took about 35 years of me
doing experiments doing trial and error
studies basically to find out
what were the variables that affected
what
and why did they do that and if i just
had two or three variables
then it would have been a year or two
but when you have
the number of variables goes up the
number of complication
you know the number of possibilities
goes up dramatically
so it took a long time to just be some
examples of these variables
like you said mental state well mental
state would be one
there's lots of various mental states
you can get into
some are more effective than others but
it would be
let's say we're doing something like
remote viewing okay if we're going to
remote view and we're going to review
targets
then there one is the is the mental
space that you're in
the attitude the feeling you know these
are all
qualitative um
subjective things so you have a mental
state of
where you're going or your mental state
my mental state where i am what's my
mental state and how do i get there
and it finds out that mental state and
attitude and beliefs
fears all that stuff are part of the
part of the equation um
it then you have to look at the various
variables how do you
approach it what tools do you use do you
have the idea that you are uh
like you say there's a camera someplace
is that your metaphor
for what's going on because we just have
to make up metaphors for things because
we don't really understand how they work
so you make up a metaphor okay there's a
camera over there
and i'm gonna see what the camera sees
and now i can scan the camera you know i
get to
i get to move it around like it's on a
ball joint you know so you
we have these metaphors and you can work
through metaphors until the metaphor
doesn't break
breaks doesn't work anymore well
it's not really a camera because these
things you know
the camera wouldn't wouldn't see but i
see those things
so it's just a matter of testing
trying to if you do it enough you start
seeing
patterns you start seeing things that
work and things that don't
you start seeing similarities between
approaches
between healing and remote viewing and
other things
so i just we stuck with the paranormal
things because those are the evidential
things
and without evidence well you're just
out there
stuff happens and you could be making
all that up you know you could be
dreaming it you need the
you need the evidence to to verify it
so those are the kinds of things just
working with it looking for patterns
looking for structure looking for things
that
seem to always work and trying to figure
out why they worked
so i sat down in in the late 1990s
probably middle to late 1990s and
started to write this thing
and the reason i started writing it up
is because somebody asked me about it
somebody said hey tom you know how does
how does reality work
and i said well i think i could tell you
that and i found out that there are lots
of holes in it
a lot of my thoughts were just fuzzy you
know they weren't really
very sharp they were very fuzzy so
i thought i need to put this down on
paper because writing
forces clarity it's you know a fuzzy
sentence is obvious a fuzzy thought we
just kind of slide
over it and because we think we know
what it means we never notice how fuzzy
it is
so i wrote it down and the writing
process took about five years
and during that time i learned a lot
because i
found a lot of the fuzzy places a lot of
the holes
and i started working on filling them up
you know
how you know more research was required
really
to fill up those holes better ideas
better models better metaphors
and how many hours per day would you
work approximately on the big toe
on that big toe probably
almost a day's worth probably anywhere
from you know
four on a light day to maybe eight or
nine
on a heavy day and you're still on the
side doing experiments
or you had abandoned that you took a
break just to write out this no no i was
still doing experiments i had i actually
got my experiment and actually
took on more life because now he's
experimenting for very specific
issues not just understanding the big
thing but
you know what's okay here's a problem
there's a logical issue
you know you get from a to b and i can't
express that logically it's like oh a
miracle happened so i'm in a then i'm in
b
well a miracle happens isn't
satisfactory to science
i had to figure out what was the logic
that took me between these
these steps so in any case
i write the book and i learn a lot
because i have to do a lot of research
as i go and a lot of thinking and trying
to find model
and what i ended up doing was i had
these
facts of consciousness that i had come
to think as of facts my research
this is the way it is like one such fact
would be that consciousness is
fundamental
and the physical world is not the
physical world is a subset
okay and the reason i came to that
conclusion is that i could
with my mind modify things in the
physical reality
but i could not do it the other way
around
the physical reality did not
fundamentally change anything in
consciousness but things in
consciousness could fundamentally change
things in the physical world
therefore the flow of causality flowed
from consciousness to the physical
which meant consciousness was the
superset
physical reality was a subset so i
understood that the consciousness
was a fundamental thing the fundamental
thing
and that the physical world was somehow
a subset of that
but the exact somehow wasn't clear yet
so i kept
working on that so i had all of these
facts of consciousness things that i had
done
enough and experimented with enough that
i knew were
real things and of course i had a lot of
facts of the physical because i'm a
physicist and that's what we study
the facts of the physical world how the
physical world works
so i started looking for a model one
model
one elegant not complicated
understanding that would explain
all facts both sides and
eventually i came up with that and that
is what i call
a big toe and it's a big toe because
it not only unifies quantum mechanics
and relativity like a little toe should
but it also explains experience
the subjective world so in other words
you you should be able to take this
model
and take your subjective experiences
and explain them why you end up with
that experience what does that
experience
mean you know it's significance how is
it related to other experiences
so it explains the subjective world as
well as the objective world
yes i can take that theory of
consciousness which actually my book
my big toe trilogy was really more a
theory of consciousness than anything
else though i knew it was the superset
and about two years after i published
that
in 2003
i got the aha moment where i could
derive physics i could derive relativity
in quantum mechanics
from those same ideas i could explain
them
and when i did that you know
quantum mechanics stopped being weird
science and just became logical science
like
any other science it isn't weird it's it
not only turns out to be
logical but it turns out to be necessary
it couldn't be any other way
the only you know the only way that's
going to work is if you describe
particles as probability distributions
that's how you
you see a pro you know see a particle as
a probability distribution it has to be
that way
there's no other way that it could work
and the
relativity is fundamentally driven from
the
the fact that the speed of light's a
constant
you know the speed of light's a constant
is the it's kind of the
the what the mystery
the big mystery in uh relativity theory
if you have that information then
relativity becomes kind of
known i mean the rest of it's just math
but that's the that's kind of the thing
that isn't understood in relativity and
that came out to be just perfectly
obvious too it couldn't be any other way
so i started looking then at the
various paradoxes in physics things that
just don't make sense
like um oh there's a lot of paradoxes in
physics tons of them
all the fundamental things in physics
have no
source basically as physics
understands it now like time where does
time come from
space where did space come from where
does mass come from where does charge
come from
you know where does spin come from all
of these all the fundamentals of physics
if you ask a physicist well you know
where's that come from they'll say well
we don't know it just is
so there isn't any good theory that
explains
where all these things come from where
did that ball of plasma and big bang
theory come from
because our universe didn't exist yet it
had to predate our universe well what do
you mean
something that ball of plasma predated
our universe
if everything that's real is defined as
our universe then that's a problem
that's a paradox
so there's lots of these paradoxes there
was the xeno effect which is how you can
if if you have a atom that goes from
state a to state b or a system
on a continuous yeah so if you keep
measuring it and measuring it never gets
out of a
even though normally it would go from a
to b say in a minute
you can measure it for all day and if
you keep measuring it
close enough then it'll never go to b so
those kinds of paradoxes all had a very
straightforward solution i even looked
at
chaos theory and could come up with a
fundamental reason why chaos theory
works the way it
works why you have these areas of
chaotic
motion let's say in a in a liquid flow
you know high velocity liquid flow and
then those areas will kind of get calm
and then the calmness will float around
in different areas and other areas will
erupt into
into uh you know higher
higher velocity more chaotic things you
know so weather patterns and
and water flow and other chaotic kind of
events
and that's not known why does it work
that and now we know the math
okay you know you have two differential
equations
will uh you know produce that kind of a
thing but
why does the world work that way you
know math doesn't cause reality
math just models reality you know you
have to
have to understand that math isn't the
cause of things it's just
a way of modeling it so in any way so
this
it turned out that it did drive
physics reasonably enough and right now
i have
a set of quantum mechanics experiments
that i am
having done in southern california
they call it cal poly california
polytechnical institute
i have a scientist there who is who's
doing these for me
it's taking a long time it's slow but
it's one guy working part time so it
just
takes a long time and these experiments
will
produce more evidence that
reality is not material but is
is uh information based which is what a
lot of
physicists say these days our reality is
information based
and it also shows that
it's it provides evidence that
consciousness is the computer
it's information based that means it can
be calculated
it can be calculated then you need a you
know where is it calculated what's
calculating it
and the answer to that is consciousness
is the computer so now all of this
sounds very abstract
but there is logic that ties it all
together
so just you know for your listeners who
i i assume you tend to be a science guy
so you're you're listeners who are going
to be very objective and
science guys probably um i'm trying to
give them
an overview so it was from this
this perspective of consciousness that i
ended up
driving deriving physics and it's a very
simple
elegant model it's only got two
basic assumptions and they're not
remarkable at all one of them is that
consciousness exists
the other one is that uh evolution
exists
evolution being that if you have a
system that's self-changing and if it
has some
pressures or some uh what can we say uh
you know things that it has to do like
in our physical world that would be
procreation and survival
those are the things you need to do
those are the pressures that you have
uh so if you have a system with with
pressures in a certain way it will
change itself in order to you know
procreate
or survive in our physical case or to do
whatever
its particular environmental pressures
are internal and external environment
so it will tend to satisfy those those
things
so that's all from that i can
pretty much deductively
create this whole theory from beginning
to end
there are no other grand assumptions
nothing weird no
no no place where and then a miracle
happens and you've got
you know something else going on so
that's the
that's the basic theory it's uh it's
logical it's
science in the same way that
say evolution
you know evolution theory about our
planet you know you give a
evolutionist a and he will
explain to you how that cell evolved
into all the things we have on the
planet
you know given talking about life you
know biologically right
we're talking about evolution of life
not the evolution of rocks but the
evolution of the living things
on the planet you give him a living cell
and he will tell you how that cell was
just a single-celled thing and then it
got to be a multiple cell thing and he
will go on and how it
diverged and how the environment you
know allowed these
these mutations and on and on and on and
he'll end up with our world
based on the assumption that the living
cells
existed to begin with because the
biologist is
a little hard-pressed to say exactly
where those you know
where that cell came from although he's
got a hand-waving argument that says oh
well you had the right proteins and the
right amino acids just happened to
come together in a little maybe
electrical shock from some lightning or
something and
voila you got a living cell but that's a
hand-waving conjecture argument that's
not really solid logical argument it's
like uh
you know so i do the same thing i can
start with where did consciousness come
from
and i have to start with well
consciousness started at a
at its simplest level its simplest level
is basically an awareness a simple
awareness that is aware
that it can be in two different states
it can be this way and it can be that
way that's a binary
that's all that's it that's the that's
the one cell that the biologists have
that's my
consciousness cell if you will and from
there
you can just see how you can follow the
logic of evolution
and you can build up the nature of
consciousness consciousness is an
information system
consciousness is you know awareness is
awareness of what
you're aware of something and as
something you're aware of
is can be can be you know seen as
information is what you're aware of what
about us that's what we're aware of we
have five senses
and our reality is the data we collect
from those five senses it's information
so consciousness that is an information
system
information systems if
let's start with a with an information
well we'll call it information system
but let's say all of its bits
are random if all of its bits are random
there is no information
that's the highest entropy condition
that it can be in
is all of its bits are random no
information
if it orders some of those bits and
particularly if it gives that order
some meaning then you have information
is created so information systems evolve
by
lowering entropy that's just the nature
of
okay we're going to get to the specifics
the technicalities so you don't know
this but
most of the time when i interview
someone i spend about two weeks prepping
and for you i spent maybe two months so
i have
i have here large legal paper tiny fonts
maybe six five and a half
pages of questions okay
all right well that's fine so okay okay
my first question yeah i'm assuming your
listeners just don't really
have any idea who i am and what i'm
doing right right i'm trying to yeah
that's
totally fine a little background but
okay go ahead with your questions
well one is that you mentioned that you
unify relativity and quantum mechanics
and i i didn't see well i see what
you're saying is that okay there can be
a
limit so an information speed limit that
is c we'll just call that c
and then quantum mechanics is quantum
mechanics but but that's special
relativity not general
i'm curious about some of the if i can
get into quantum field theory i don't
know if
you can yeah okay so there's a couple
problems in in qft so
general relativity is non-renormalizable
and i'm curious
if there's a way in your theory to
overcome that
well you know the way i see general
relativity is basically you start with
special relativity which is a very
simple
little you know algebra thing and
then you know we had a model of gravity
at that point and that was you know
that the force of gravity is is some
constant g
you know times mass one times mass two
over the square of the distance g m m
over r squared
okay that was our model of gravity
masses attract each other
but of course there was no real good
reason why masses should attract each
other but
that'd just be one of those things it
just is in science so
that was that was gravity and
once we had special relativity
distance and time kind of took on a
different meaning
and the relationship between them
started to
you know obviously there were
connections
between distance and time that
kind of confuses this issue of the
distance between them
for gravity so einstein looked for a
more
general solution which is general
relativity
and he came up with this solution that
you know geometry
of space time so we had space time now
and space time had
geometry it was a surface it flowed it
had
peaks and dips and gravity were dips
in the space time so you'd get something
that got into space time where there was
a dip
and you'd slide down the dip to the
lower energy state
because things naturally move from the
higher energy state to the lower energy
energy state so then we had a whole new
idea of gravity
it was warps and changes in spacetime so
where you have
mass you have space-time warping you
know so the you know the old
metaphor of you know the bowling ball
and the trampoline
kind of thing is is what you get so
he took gravity and turned it into a
geometric model where he took our
you know relativity turned that into a
geometric model and then
people have ever since been working out
the logical consequences
of that you know of that concept in the
math
in the mathematics so
his theory was basically a theory of
general relativity is really a theory of
gravity
in my mind that's it's that's its basic
thing all right now
it had some problems and the way i look
at it from a bigger picture
both of those models gmm over
r square and the space time model of
relativity
neither model is exactly right
neither model is without its issues
both models give you results
within their own realm of doing things
within
with with the faster you know very fast
speeds of things okay relativistic
speeds
and with very tiny things then the
you know the uh einstein's model made
more sense because it
it worked in a larger range of reality
but they're just different views
different ways of expressing
the same thing different models of
modeling the same thing
so it's not that one's right and one's
wrong it's that if you look at it from
this viewpoint okay from the viewpoint
where
things aren't that fast and not that
small you know from the
our regular kind of observational world
well gmm over r square works pretty good
matter of fact we do a lot of good you
know
space exploration mainly based on things
like that you know it's a good model
so if you need to worry about the
high velocities and small things then
you need something else
you need quantum mechanics and you need
and you need relativity for the high
speeds
so you know
both of them are going to have
limitations i don't see that his model
is
you know i don't know i guess we could
say it's more general
it's a more general model but it has
issues but my model is not
you know i don't worry too much about
the details
of the way the you know the logical
details
inside the theory i'm one of those
persnickety equation people that you
reference in the book
and that book by the way it's a huge
book usually i can get through a book in
well in a certain a quick amount of time
but then this one
like i told you i've been listening to
it primarily
for two months maybe more yeah well
it's packed it's packed with information
yes
went through all your slides too and
this was the only slide that i
couldn't particularly comprehend so at
one point we're gonna go through this
and i also wanted to know just as an
aside why don't you use latex
that it's it's aggravating to me to read
equations no longer in
latex because i'm so spoiled by the
beauty i was
saying i was writing this book for
everyday joe i wasn't writing it for
scientists
to me one of the one of the things that
this book
these books were supposed to do is
provide an on-ramp
for left brains on exploration yeah
on-ramp yeah a way
to get to an on-ramp to the bigger
picture
okay the bigger picture is kind of the
nature of reality from
from the biggest picture now people with
that
live with logical process you know which
is mostly scientists but not just
scientists even
you know carpenters and other people who
think logically to do what they do
those kind of left brain people don't
have an on-ramp to the bigger picture
there's lots of on-ramps for
right-brained people who tend to get
things intuitively
but logical people can't go there
you know they they get there and they
say oh where's the proof
you know where's the where's the logic
it's not there and
if the logic doesn't go then they can't
go either
so i wanted to write a book that was for
the every day
joe but something that would also
provide an on-ramp for the guys that
require logical process
so that was what i was trying to do was
a balance between
all of those things i wasn't writing the
first physicist i wasn't
just writing it for you know technical
people i wanted everybody
to be able to read it and get it
so that's the nature of those of those
books
but the material is dense if you
read it quickly you'll miss most of it
that's
probably what you found out you got to
really read it because it is a logical
flow like
like math you know you can't just skip
through a math book
you can't speed read a math book you got
to read each thing because that thing
kind of takes upon the last still yeah
builds upon the last builds upon the
next and is going someplace
and you have to take the whole trip and
you have to take it slow enough that you
you don't just intellectually get it but
you have to get it on a little deeper
level
if you just intellectually get it you
can go through the book on uh-huh uh-huh
uh-huh
all the way to the end and you get out
the other side
and okay you could discuss it
intellectually but you don't really get
it at all
you don't see the bigger picture you've
never made the journey you know
so that's it is a hard book to read
you know i i've got one one guy who
wrote to me he said
he's read the book he read the book once
and he read it like two or three weeks
and he realized he didn't understand it
so now he's reading which one because
there's three the first one he wrote
all three in three weeks read all three
of them in three weeks he's kind of a
speed reader guy who reads things
quickly
and he got to the end of it and he says
he didn't have any idea what it was all
about so he went back and now
at the end on i think this is like his
third reading he says he reads 10 pages
a day
no more and that's his
that's his limit he says more than 10
pages i get confused
there's something efficacious about
reading a book till the end and not
getting the full grasp and then going
back to it
it's like at least you get the table of
contents you know where you're going
yeah and then
you get the basic big ideas you just
don't get the understanding so yeah
there's
there's something to be said for as long
as you go back as long as you go back
yeah okay
so i need help with this on-ramp because
i'm somewhat of a fool
and i've been i can intellectually
understand some of it but
but i'm having a i guess you would say
i'm having a difficult time
like like we were talking about i'm
thinking about equations as well so
there's some problems
when someone says they have a small toe
forget about big right and i'm
interested in big totally
100 that's what the channel is about how
do you explain consciousness free will
god
if there's any well also here's the
interesting question what does an
explanation
mean is an explanation simply the
mathematical equations
is it as simple as you start with
assumptions and then derive from there
like what does an explanation mean well
that's a difficult question too but
either way
i'm interested in the in a huge token
okay you just told that we
okay to answer that one the
mathematics does not explain it
basically describes
things don't again mathematics doesn't
cause things to happen
well wow whoa all right tom let's play
with this because that depends if you're
a politeness some platonist would say
that's the real world the real world is
the
idealized mathematical realm and somehow
this world is caused from that now
someone like penrose
also he doesn't come right out and say
that but he alludes to it
well i would be in the idealist camp but
this world is computed it is a virtual
reality
it's a computed reality consciousness is
the computer
okay but it doesn't mean that
analytical equations is how it's
computed
there's computer science too it's like
uh you know there's a difference between
uh
your your guy doing you know you you
gave me two people that you wanted to
talk about you know the one guy's doing
geometry
and the other guy's doing computer
processing
you know he's looking at links and and
networks
you know you're looking like you don't
know what i'm talking about
uh no what are you talking about i'm
talking about wolfram
oh yes yeah that's right that's right
eric weinstein yeah weinstein and
wolfram right so one guy's just looking
at geometry and equations the math
but the other guy's really looking at
computer processing
computation computational stuff it's
different okay
so what math does you know
if if you understand how the reality is
being computed
well then yes you you know you have a
direct you know a direct understanding
of the algorithms but our reality is
a couple of things here one math does
not
actually explain math
predicts math describes so let's just
take a
a i've got a charge here say a positive
charge you can't see my hands
positive charge here and i'm going to
i'm going to measure
uh the force that it'll have on a
negative charge here
okay now because this is action at a
distance
i'm going to say that there's a field a
magnetic field between them and that
field then is what interacts with this
this
charge appears and pulls it down right
it's a field thing
well there are no fields fields are
imaginary
fields don't exist in a virtual reality
you don't need fields all you need is
the equation that computes the force
the force is real the field is just
mathematics that describes the
experience you see
it predicts i can predict what this
force is because i can do the
mathematics
but a prediction isn't a cause i can
predict when the bus is going to come to
the bus station but
i don't cause the bus to come to the bus
station i just can predict it
so you have to you have to not take the
math as seriously as most of the
physicists take the math
they're trying to describe something if
their mathematics is not exactly the
same as the computations that are
creating it
and there's a lot of math that's you
know the analytical math that you think
of as
math besides the computational math is
quite
different so it's combinations of these
things
and now the way the reality actually
works though this physical reality we
kind of need to say this otherwise
you know you're going to get wounded up
with over the you know over the math
and that is that you have a rule set
this virtual reality was created not by
programmers programming it but it has
evolved
it's an evolving thing it started with a
initial conditions
and a rule set the initial conditions
was that
big bang description it was that ball of
plasma
high temperature high pressure whatever
initial conditions and then the run
button was hit
and those initial conditions change
according to the
rule set now ruleset is what we think of
as physics
so that rule set is primarily
deterministic
so it has random things in it
but it's pretty much deterministic with
some randomness added because some
events are just
random as a good description so anyway
then the world that we're talking about
is not
calculated from that rule set
the world that we experience out here in
the physical world
is a probabilistic world because
calculating everything from the ground
up starting with quarks
and working your way up is not
it's untenable it's untenable it doesn't
work
i wouldn't say it's impossible it's just
there's also at least wolfram would say
something called computational
irreducibility which means that even if
we were to try to compute
the actions of the next say 10 minutes
the amount of computational power that
would be needed would be the size of the
room or the size of the universe and so
you can't do it yeah anyway
just exactly skirting right it's hurting
you yeah it just doesn't make any sense
so what happens is that
the rule set creates the probability
distributions
what's the rule set do you mean the
physical law yeah the physical laws the
rule set remember we start with initial
conditions and a rule set yeah
and we punch the run button and the
initial conditions change according to a
rule set we end up with this universe
okay so it's all just evolving initial
conditions evolve
under the rule set and it evolves and
then we can just pick up with the
physicist you know the whole thing
evolves and the biologists and the whole
thing evolves
so that's the virtual reality that's how
it's computed it's computed in
consciousness it's a simulation
and it's not it's not that somebody
programs it so
if you understand that now when we do
something here
let's say we're just going to a good
example is we fire a cannon simple
example because cannon's a very simple
machine
it's a tube with a ball in it and
gunpowder behind it you light the
gunpowder and it increases the pressure
and out goes the ball
okay that's simple now if you tried to
describe that in detail at the
even the molecular level you couldn't do
it it'd be too hard
or it would take a lot of computer thing
power
so what you do is you describe it with
statistics with probability
and you say okay here's a canon made out
of certain kinds of material
you know constructed a certain way the
barrel isn't really exactly a cylinder
there's lumps and creases
in it and the ball isn't precisely a
sphere it's got
things in it too and the powder doesn't
burn particularly whatever so you have
the cannonball if you fire the cannon 10
times that ball will not land in exactly
the same place it'll land in a bunch of
different places
it'll produce a pattern that's called a
you know the dispersion
of the cannon and you represent that
with a probability distribution
now in a virtual reality the and you
have a war going on with these cannons
somebody fires a cannon
and the rendering engine that renders
the virtual reality goes into that
that dispersion that probability
distribution
randomly picks out something that is
probable
that's where it puts the k you know
possible and that's where it puts the
cannonball
you see so you don't have the system
doesn't have to to model
the whole process in detail it develops
probability distributions based on the
rule set
and then it can use these probability
distributions to create
the canon in the real world so now we
fire a canon
and the system just puts a ball at a
particular place
okay so an analogy would be fairly
simple it would be like a video game
it has a probability distribution like
think of it like that then just scale it
up to your experience
exactly so that's the way it works so
from from my viewpoint what's going on
here in our in our physical world in pmr
okay that's at the probabilistic level
everything here's what hits me here's
what hits me right away okay so there's
the matrix obviously like simulation
hypothesis and then there's also donald
hoffman if you've heard of
yeah it's consciousness theorist okay so
let's compare and contrast yours
and the matrix well let's say simulation
in general
so simulated reality and then donald
hoffman so where do you agree and
disagree with those two
hypothesis hypotheses uh
my i also have a you know i would fit
under a simulation hypothesis too
my you could put my work into that
category
but mine is very different than it's not
that we're being simulated by higher
intelligent beings
right so what happened yeah what
happened these other
these other guys doing their their
virtual realities somebody asked well
you know who's what's the computer
who are the programmers and they're
stuck for an answer
yeah they don't know you get an infinite
regress which is illogical
that doesn't make any sense there is no
infinite regress
in physics infinity doesn't really exist
as a physical
thing all right so we have i don't but
okay okay so okay let's just say on this
path for just this okay
all right all right so they come up with
something that's this
way stretch you know hand waving thing
it's our future selves or something that
are doing this
well that's a pretty that's a pretty
huge leap you know
that's one of those in a miracle
occurred so i don't go there with that
kind of a big
big leap so i have
that uh you know consciousness is the
computer and i can
logically explain why consciousness
would want to make this virtual reality
you know that's
that's a lot that's part of the logical
process that gets
that will be you know explained and what
the point of it is and the purpose and
the whole
thing comes out very logically but then
i have this
reality that isn't computing all the
details
it's basically computing probabilities
and it go it puts as much detail in it
as it needs
so if we're taking a measurement and now
i take my my millimeter wave radar
and i track that cannonball now it has
to
simulate that it only does what it needs
in order to save on computational power
or for what reason
it just does it only does as much detail
as it needs to do for the measurements
that are being taken
so here we are we are the avatars our
bodies we're the avatars
who we actually are ourselves we're
consciousness
we're an individuated unit of
consciousness okay we're not the avatar
the avatar's just the player quick aside
quick aside come right back we'll come
right back you said we're an
individuated unit of consciousness now
what about some of the proposals that we
comprise multiple consciousnesses vying
for
power so when you split the corpus
callosum you know that there's two
and it seems like whenever we get mad
it's as if that personality that
consciousness comes out is
whenever we get let's say anxious it's
like that one wins
and it's as if they're their own
consciousness they're their own little
personalities
vying inside our head fighting now how
do we make sense of that
when we say that we're a unified
individual unit of consciousness
you are an individuated unit of
consciousness and you
you have two ways of processing data and
this is there's two
two things two sides to this that i need
to give you one
you have two ways of processing data you
can process data as
consciousness you are a consciousness
you process data intellectually
and you can process data intuitively
those are two
different ways that your consciousness
processes data
okay now the when you in when you use
your intellect to process data the major
tool you use is called logic
and logic is a very precise tool but the
problem with using your intellect is
mostly you don't have enough information
to make a deductive right you know a
deduct you could use deductive logic
because you just don't have enough
information i agree so
on the intuitive side so you've got this
you've got
this precise tool called logic
and an intellect but it needs to be
directed in what direction it doesn't
have a whole lot of information
ready information over on the intuitive
side
okay thank you so much oh no problem
yeah no problem at all i
i've been i've been doing some
transcendental meditation we can talk
about that i was
pretty much just following your advice
you said try it out for three months i
think i'm a month and a half into it
we'll talk about that too okay so okay
let me work on this so we have the
intellect and
and uh we have its logic right but we
have lousy information for the most part
very incomplete let's just say
incomplete ready information
over on the intuitive side you have your
your awareness
okay it's your mind is the tool not the
logic
it's your mind it's your awareness and
that awareness is not the precise tool
of logic
it's kind of a ratty tool because that
awareness has to do with your mind
being in a productive state not being
full of thoughts you know it needs to
focus it needs to have low noise
it needs to to not be intellectually
trying to process things the intellect
will
get in the way it needs to let that
intellect go
so it's over there but it has all the
data
it's got this this huge database of
basically everything so its data is
precise
and and and very deep uh amount of data
but the tool is ratty so you know you
have these so you have these two sides
to a person right
these two things all right now also the
person has
fear okay fear is the big problem
fear is what we're trying to evolve away
from and i can also logically say that
you know we say consciousness is
evolving it evolves to lower entropy
states
those lower entropy states are
the same as evolving toward being caring
being cooperative sharing those sorts of
things and that is a logical process too
i can explain
that as well a lot you know deductively
so we just have to accept that for now
until we get to that explanation
so if you have this the fear is the
problem and you're trying to evolve
toward becoming
love okay so if you have this fear
this fear creates self-centeredness
because fear is all about
you and it you know you so it creates
self-centeredness it creates
ego it creates beliefs you
so you have this fear now you're talking
about you get angry and suddenly
well if you didn't have the fear you
wouldn't get angry
if you got rid of that ego you wouldn't
get angry you wouldn't have those things
so basically you've got part of your
consciousness that is dysfunctional
in that it is fear-based and there's
another part of you that is
growing up that is caring and
cooperative and wanting to see bigger
pictures
and those two sometimes struggle
and get in each other's way are those
two
different consciousnesses no no no it's
just all part of the same thing
it's a consciousness that is not
very highly evolved it's a consciousness
that has fear
so and it has a lot of fear fear
manifests
your anger is coming from that fear
let's say somebody insults you says you
don't know anything about that you know
you're the dumbest person i've ever met
they insult you somehow
and you get angry about that because
it's somebody you respect or somebody
you need to respect like maybe your boss
or uh someone else so you get that kind
of an insult
well if you were completely confident if
you didn't have any fear
that info that insult would not trigger
anything it wouldn't trigger any you
wouldn't have anger
you'd be aware that that other person
is just misunderstanding and instead of
being angry
you'd have some compassion and see if
you couldn't maybe fix that
misunderstanding that they had rather
than getting
angry so it's not that you have two
different minds and two different
consciousness you just have a
consciousness that has
fear it has beliefs and it has
ego the ego and the beliefs are both
created by the fear ego
is awareness in the service of fear
that's why you get these different
things going on if you wouldn't have
that
matter of fact this will maybe uh uh
give you a cause to uh
to to think differently too if you got
rid of your fear
you as consciousness got rid of your
fear which means you're highly evolved
now
you're evolving to get rid of your fear
so you've gotten rid of your fear
at that point you don't have a
subconscious
you are entirely conscious of everything
about you everything that happens you
don't have any hidden
part there's there's you're your
sexuality you know your all the other
things that
that freud would put into an id that's
part of the subconscious and so on
you're aware of all of that
nothing's written and you don't have any
buttons to push
you don't get angry you don't get upset
you don't even get
uh stressed okay so you live in a
you you live in a place of peace and a
place of joy
and caring so that's you know
kind of going to the extreme but the
subconscious
mind of freud is really
a dysfunctional part
of the consciousness what about carl
jung because carl jung might say that
the unconscious comprises
99 of you and that it's impossible for
you to ever be
fully conscious you're always going to
have a massive amount that's unconscious
so i defer with jung in that respect
yeah no well they are having they're
making a very accurate um
description of people in general
people in general have lots of fear
this this uh this virtual reality of
ours is a schoolhouse it's an entropy
reduction trainer
if you will and most people
haven't evolved a whole lot so there's
lots and lots of fear
so freud looks at it and he says oh ego
that's a good thing
everybody needs a healthy ego and carl
young would say yeah you're never gonna
you know you're never gonna get to the
point that you know
that you don't have the shadow part of
yourself you know it's always going to
be a part of you
well it's not true it doesn't have to
always be a part of you
but it is a part of virtually everyone
because everyone has fear
and there's very few people that
ever get rid of all that fear so to make
an analogy would be like looking at the
earth and saying all the elements that
exist
are the ones that are on the earth but
they don't realize that you can combine
them and create some that are rare yeah
that's just exceptional circumstances
well freud
and and young both were
were experimentalists in a sense they
looked at people and looked at
themselves
and here's what here's what i see here's
what i see in myself here's what i see
in other people
and they're making models based on
people well
everybody almost everybody is full of
fear there may be a few exceptions but
these are extremely rare people
so if everybody's full of fear then
everybody's going to have a shadow
and if you can't get rid of yours then
you assume that nobody can get rid of
theirs either
so it's it's that sort of a thing it's
just but it's
not necessary that's the dysfunctional
part of us that's the part that
is causing us trouble makes us angry you
know it's not another mind it's not like
there's two minds struggling
it's just one consciousness trying to
grow up
trying to evolve the quality of its
consciousness
okay so here's what occurs to me when i
hear some people they're usually
more buddhist oriented or more new age
or spiritual oriented and they
dislike fear and say that we need to get
rid of fear
and i understand that fear can be
unadaptive but at the same time people
who don't feel
well if you don't feel pain let's say
that's a neurological disorder
if you don't feel fear fear is actually
necessary for the consolidation of
long-term memory for declarative memory
in particular
and there are a few patients who just
have a disorder it would be called a
disorder because it's unadaptive
where they don't feel fear and then they
can't remember much they also
have no bounds socially they come up to
your face and talk to your nose to nose
because they just don't read the cues
they don't feel the slight social fear
the slight guilt the slight shame
and those i see is also tempering
mechanisms for us to interact
so when people say eliminate your fear i
wonder
if they mean what i'm interpreting them
to mean
because it can't be all fear and also
can't be simply ego based given that
there's the startle reflex
there's like that's not under conscious
control there's
fear you know getting rid of fear
doesn't mean that you become stupid
so somebody might say well if you're not
afraid then jump off the cliff well no
i won't jump off the cliff because
that's stupid you know i
just because i don't have fear doesn't
mean i want to die you know well don't
go out and walk in the woods
where the grizzly bears are because you
know you might
run into one and that would be a problem
so you don't go out and that fear
keeps you safe the fear doesn't keep you
safe the fear
will always make things worse if you
have to go out in those woods for some
reason
and you have fear you're less likely to
survive than if you don't
okay so you don't go out in that woods
because
you're intelligent because you think
because you
you understand so it's not that fear
saves people from going out in the woods
with grizzly bears
intelligence does that being aware and
if you have to go out in that woods
because grandma who lives on the other
side of the woods
is having a problem and you need to go
then
if you're fearful you will attract bears
you will attract predators you will do
exactly the wrong thing you'll run which
is a prey
symbol and you will have you just do all
the wrong things if you
are intelligent and not afraid well then
you have come with your pepper spray and
your air horn
and you will know whether to stare in
his eye or to look at the ground you'll
know whether to run
or to walk slowly so not being afraid
is what saves you from the bears it's
the fear
is what will kill you we
we say that people you know are better
off if they have fear of the bears
because it keeps them out of the woods
well
no you see we're making
we're assigning the wrong the wrong
thing to the to the causality there it's
not the fear that's the thing that's
that's helping the fear is always a
problem it's the
it's the uh intelligent decisions good
choices making good choices is what
saves people fear always makes
everything worse
so you know you were talking about the
you know you have this uh
this automatic response let's say
a response to fear it's not the fear
that creates that
that's part of your instincts you've got
instincts that are hardwired in your
in your dna in your system and you get a
stimulus you'll give a response you know
the fight flight
you crush your leg and get a little
rubber hammer and tap it at the right
place your leg will shoot up
that's just because we have instincts we
have hard wiring
and that hard wiring will do whatever it
does it's like an if then statement
in a computer you know if you trigger it
it'll you'll get the result
so you do have those things but they're
not fear-based
fear always creates a problem
you know it's you know we
you know we don't explain sexuality to
our
young people because we think if they're
afraid of it you know we we scare them
about it
so that you know they'll be afraid
to play with it until they're much older
so we think that fear will keep them
safe you know the fear
is what gets them into trouble knowledge
will keep them safe
understanding will keep them safe not
fear
so fear is the is the problem
so what do you think of the statement
fear of god as the beginning of wisdom
well i think that's just wrong it's not
fear of god you shouldn't be fearing god
you know we just assume that there's
such a thing as god just for the sake of
the conversation
but fearing is the wrong thing you need
to understand
god and and what it means and what that
is and what the relationship that you
have is
and what's expected and what you should
be doing and if you understand
all of that then fear is just gets in
the way
fear locks you up fear keeps you from
from being you you know if you fear
something
let's say let's take that example so if
you do things let's say i
i'm because i fear god i'm going to be
nice and kind to people because god says
you should be nice and kind to people
okay so when i see somebody that you
know i can be nice to then i'll go over
and i'll be nice to them
well that is acting you're acting nice
because you have fear you're acting nice
well acting nice is civilizing but it
doesn't help you grow up any
you got to be nice and there's a big
difference between
acting kind and being kind a huge
difference
so the fear perhaps will make you act
kind
but though civilizing is not going to
help you grow up
it's not who you are you're just acting
because then some other time when it's
not convenient that kind
you won't be kind because you're really
self-centered and if it's all about you
you'll be unkind but when anybody's
looking you'll act kind because
you want to have a good reputation for
being a nice guy so you see
if you're not really kind you haven't
grown up any
so that's the thing so the fear of god
may make you act differently
but it's not about acting it's about
being
and the fear will never make you be
anything the fear
can only make you act won't make you
change who you are it'll make you just
be
i don't know what to say duplicious so
it creates another problem
so now you have the problem that you're
living your image
not who you are and that'll cause all
kinds of
issues you know make you neurotic when
you aren't in consonance with who you
really are you're living an image
so fear is you know
give me another example of good fear
well as i was reading your book
i see plenty of similarities to jordan
peterson if you're familiar with him at
all such as an emphasis on individualism
and the primacy of your experience also
peterson does say that there's a book
called ordinary men you should read that
book and it's about how ordinary people
can become monsters
and shoot pregnant women at the back of
their head even though you're an
ordinary person he said
you should read that because you should
know what your shadow is in the union
terms
because then you would become fearful of
that and then
you would start to act right now that's
one aspect that i see you differing
from peterson yeah right i don't
again acting right is civilizing but
being right is growing
it's becoming it's growing up it's
becoming something else when you just
act
you're not actually changing who you are
you're not becoming
better person okay i see that fear now
i'll
act better civilizing but not really
helpful because
as soon as you get between a rock and a
hard place
that acting that image is gonna come
right off
it's it's not even skin deep
it's a suit you wear it's a behavior
that you that you do
but it's not really who you are so
all you're doing is is acting nicer
so yeah you okay you look at this
horrible thing and now you'll act better
now that's civilizing but not really
helpful it doesn't take you any place
you got to be
better not just act so if we all had
this great
uh you know illusionary persona that we
carry around with us
and we all act nice to each other and
are polite and kind and
and so on well like i say said civil
lines that's nice
but as soon as something horrible
happens to where now that
that nice persona you know
isn't uh isn't functioning for you
anymore because now you're in a
life-and-death situation well you're
going to shoot that pregnant woman
because that's the only thing that's
going to save your life because
somebody else has told you to do that
and they're going to shoot you if you
don't
so you have fear fear of death
perhaps and you degenerate to what you
really are
so when the going gets tough people
degenerate to what they really are
what's inside that's why ordinary people
can do
horrendous things because they are
walking
images they're not really so much
nice people as they act that way so
i say that that's the difference yes i
would disagree with that the whole point
isn't for us to act better it's for us
to become
better yeah okay see let's not harp on
this
but i'm trying to make sense of it
myself so please forgive me if it sounds
like
just playing devil's advocate yeah no
dude you're helping me with that on-ramp
so
yeah okay see the way that i see it
currently
is that it's not just that you need fear
you also need pleasure and both are twin
mechanisms that
push you forward in a propitious manner
so in a salutary place
so let's say you mentioned civilized
okay how about this
people who lack guilt who lack shame
there's a term for them and it's called
psychopaths and not all
serial killers kill because of fear in
fact they kill because it makes them
feel
well first of all sometimes it's
sexually gratifying at least for them
and then sometimes it increases their
sense of worth it increases their power
but i don't see it as they're killing
because someone's going to kill them
like the example that you mentioned i
don't see them killing out of
fear and i see plenty of harm that can
be done in the absence of fear
and i see plenty of good that can be
done in the presence of fear that's why
i'm having a difficult time
with the claims that we need to
eliminate fear totally okay
now the person that you see who's
psychotic and killing or doing something
horrible out of fear
not out of fear they are doing that out
of fear you're not seeing fear
as a fundamental thing at the core of
their being
you're seeing fear in the sense of what
they're afraid of
intellectually you're only thinking
about them as an intellect
not as a as a consciousness and as
consciousness has fear
okay the reason that person is doing
that killing is because they have
they have a fear they have a fear of not
being good enough they have a fear
of um you know the world uh
is treating them badly they have a lot
of self-centeredness it's all about them
the fear let's say they were you know
badly treated as a child and that
creates
that creates fear they have social
situations that create fear
they feel like they're they're the
victim and
they don't have guilt because they
justify
everything in their mind as being okay
and those aren't real people anyway
you know so they they do all those
things and yes that's that's a
psychopath but it's not because they
don't have fears because they do have
fear fear is at the core of all of those
things matter of fact
i would say that if you take all of the
psychiatric you know we have this book
of psychiatric illnesses
that are listed and if you take that you
would find that if you eliminated all
the ones that were
basically biological based you know
don't make enough serotonin or something
like that
brain damage if you take all the ones
that are not
physical based i'd say that
almost all of them if not all of them
are fear-based
every one of those illnesses is a fear
at the root
people are fearful reason people get
angry is because they feel
that other they fear that other people
don't appreciate them they feel that
other people don't like them or other
people are going to put them down that
they
they feel inside they're not worthy
they're not good enough they have all
this fear so when somebody
says something to them that's an insult
you know they they roar up because of
that fear
or you get the psychopath who kills
because he had a you know a traumatic
childhood where his mother
beat him every day or something and he's
got this issue with women
and he's got probably other problems as
well which may also be biological as
well as psychological
but he takes that out the women he's
killing
isn't they're not really you know
they're not really
women that he's killing he's killing the
symbol he's killing something
that is a symbol of his that's causing
his pain that's what he's doing
but he's doing that because of fear
because he's got this so i'm talking
about fear not just
being afraid and wanting to run away i'm
talking about fear is a very fundamental
dysfunctional thing
that's at the core of most
everybody's consciousness and it's the
thing we need to get rid of
okay that's somewhat different than what
i hear from most i don't know what to
call them but let's say spiritual types
or new age types or whatever it may be
that say that we must in its entirety
eliminate fear
because the way that you've explicated
fear is just simply
what's negative for you and what i see
as fear is as a specific
neurological feeling that's separate
from anxiety because there are different
neurological pathways for
anxiety for disgust for rancor for
resentment
than there is for fear like you can
actually well i don't know of any
studies that have done this but i'm sure
you can take out one with and
leave the others alone and experience
one and leave the others alone as well
so that's why when you mentioned well
this person has a bitterness about
reality i would call that bitterness
or i would call that rancor i wouldn't
call that fear
and this and the rank or come from it
comes right okay
right i hear that i hear that plenty
yeah i hear that plenty and i'm
i'm having a difficult time
understanding how that's true
or how that can be shown to be true
other than you take psychedelics and
then the person has some
breakthrough where they've eliminated
her and now all of a sudden they're
acting in a more adaptive manner
but let's put that aside i guess okay we
can talk about that another time okay
okay yeah yeah think about fear as the
as a
fundamental creator of all those other
things
you know of all those other negative
things that you're talking about that if
you didn't have fear
think of it this way think of a person
who doesn't have fear think think of a
person who is
love now love is about other not about
self
there is actually one known patient who
just couldn't experience fear
and i think the name's sm046 and she had
a horrible horrible
life and it was horrible to people but
when they say
couldn't experience fear that doesn't
mean that she didn't have
fear it just means that she didn't
process it she refused to process it she
refused to act
on it she refused to experience it
it didn't mean she doesn't have it
okay the reason that she can't process
it is probably because she does
have a lot of fear can't deal with it
can't connect to it so she's pushed it
all away
and none of that none of that
bothers her anymore she's just somewhat
like repression
yeah somewhat like repression yeah you
get to the point you can repress
all of that so people can do anything
you like and you just sit there and
ignore it because
you don't really care to even be alive
anyway you know you just are
like a robot you've you've no you've
given up connecting and caring
and then you're a sociopath well you
give up connecting and caring because of
fear
so yes you can that person would maybe
have no guilt or have no
fear but that doesn't mean they don't
express the fear so when you do
something scary they don't jump or they
don't say oh get that spider off my arm
or anything
because they're past the point of caring
about any of that
and that's because they have fear fear
and fear and love are the opposite
things
okay so love is about other and
other you know it's how can i help not
what can i get
what can i do yeah it's all about giving
not taking it's a it's about
uh you know other people
and it's not that you don't you no
longer are aware of yourself of course
you are
you know it's just that you you
what makes you happy what motivates you
what gets you to do things
what uh what
makes you uh you know what makes you
smile is helping
being a part of other people's solutions
you care about others
yeah you still take a shower in the
morning because you care about yourself
you know you want to wash the dirt off
but it's that's not your primary
motivator in life as opposed to your
primary motivator being
about you so that's the thing if you
don't have
fear then you don't get angry
and the reason that you will probably
also never have guilt
is because you'll never do anything to
ever
feel guilty about because you care about
people you feel guilty when you do
something
you know rude to somebody else well you
do that because of
fear so it's a it's just a matter of
you know you're seeing it on a you're
seeing the results
of having fear and naming those results
as things in themselves rather than as
creations of fear so i'm reducing it to
two
fundamental aspects of being and that's
fear and love
and you can everything else all the rest
of psychology
can be explained in terms of just those
things
of fear and love and you can see how the
fear creates all these other conditions
that you does the fear come from the
intellect and love comes from the
intuitive
part of you or no it's not like that at
all that fear is a part of you it's also
down at your core it's part of your
intuitive self it's
it's part of your consciousness your
consciousness
is trying to evolve
out of its fear it's trying to grow up
okay
that's the dysfunctional part that's the
that's the random bits
it's okay when you say my consciousness
it's a bit of a strange
phrase because it's like i'm not my
consciousness it's almost as if
it's a separate item like this cup so do
you mean to say like that or is it just
a useful way of
it's just a useful way of phrasing
because almost everybody thinks that
they're their body
yeah i see it i see if i talk about
consciousness
if i talk about consciousness it's this
big something in the sky
but your consciousness basically is what
you are if
if you thought of your body as an avatar
and you were consciousness then i could
just say you
well you have this you have that but
most people don't think that way they
think of
me as the body right so i say your
consciousness because of
because of that so okay so sorry to go
back you're saying that
fear is a deep part of one's
consciousness and it needs to be there
because
it's trying to evolve it doesn't need to
be there it just is there
it's there because you because the
conscious hasn't evolved
yet consciousness comes in potential
it has potential to do things okay it's
an awareness
it makes choices it has the potential to
make good choices a potential to make
bad choices
so it is mostly potential and until it
has
experience that potential is just his
potential
it has experience by making choices and
if it makes
choices that are toward caring and
kindness and love
then you know it's evolving if it makes
choices
that are self-centered and and you know
mean-spirited and that sort of thing
then it de-evolves
so consciousness has potential now you
take consciousness
as it existed originally in
this consciousness system and think of
that as like a big
chat room you have all these individual
units of consciousness and what
consciousness does is it communicates
and makes choices that's what
consciousness does so it's interesting
that related to os or is that's
completely different than os
no that is that's really
before os that's
prior to os is there an acronym that
you've said in the book
about the consciousness is interacting
with one another because everything
you're saying
remember tom i've been listening to your
voice for two months
okay so everything you're saying i'm
trying to relate it back to what i've
learned
yeah uh if this is actually what you
said this would be
as we as we move from
uh um
it's in that transition okay so auo just
for the people listening
is and then awoom is oh please
okay quick aside yeah um
is um i don't know it's gonna be hard
for me to come up with these too
uh unbounded
i don't know i'd have to look them up i
wrote that book
what 20 absolute unbounded oneness was
one yeah absolute bounded
oneness that's a um oh no
that's auo right absolute you unbounded
oneness okay and and then what's
absolutely and
something manifold all right a-u-m
don't worry i can cut this out if we can
if we can i don't know
i don't remember a long time i don't use
those terms anymore usually i use
lcs for a larger consciousness system
which is kind of the aum
aum that i ended up with just becomes a
larger conscious system and i used that
term
for so long that i haven't used those
acronyms for probably 15 years
and you know how acronyms are if you
don't use them for a long period of time
they disappear but anyway it was in the
process that consciousness
evolved from a monolithic thing
a consciousness to multiple
consciousnesses and it did that because
that was on its path to
decreasing its entropy there's more
possibilities
okay there's more structure there's more
things that you can be
if you're a set of of uh
individuated consciousnesses that can
interact with free will
now the possibilities go up whereas if
you just have one monolithic
consciousness
there's only so much you can do because
you're limited by your beliefs by your
attitudes by other things
so that's a you know cells did the same
thing you had single cell things and
these single celled things were very
limited there's only so much that you
can do with single sales
but if you get multiple sales working
together
now you can make something more complex
more ordered lower entropy and then you
can get
you know organizations of cells like our
body you know we have livers and hearts
and organs and things where
specialization of of sales
and now it's even more complex more
flexible
more capable of doing more things
because of the
because of that additional order that
you have and it's not just
random order it's order that's
meaningful that works together that
cooperates
you know with each other so it's the
same thing consciousness had to find
that same thing it was one monolithic
thing
and it decided that that was limiting it
couldn't lower its entropy
very quickly that way so it created
subsets of itself
and those subsets then each had free
will and they interact with each other
and now the pr the potential
of the whole system goes up it's bigger
entropy is lowered you have a more
complex
ordering of things so now you have these
individuals but all they are is like in
a big chat room they communicate
and they make choices okay they have
potential
but they're not growing very quickly
either because
why does entropy increase when there's
more potential no entropy decreases
i'm sorry did i say no sorry why does no
what i misspoke
why does entropy decrease and not
increase when this entropy decreases
because
you have there's more things you can do
one measure of entropy is that
is disorder okay that's one measure of
entropy
so entropy is a measure of
disorder another measure of entropy is
entropy is a measure of the ability of a
system to do work
to do things those are both different
but equivalent
ways of looking at entropy so if we look
at it as just
order then you have more order
if you have a more highly evolved
structure
okay and you have more ability to do
things more potential
more more work that you can do if you
have interactions of things rather than
just one
monolithic thing these interactions can
can
can you know challenge each other can
build things whereas this one thing
doesn't
it's the same thing with one single cell
multiple cell
i can probably show you where my
confusion lies if i write it
and then you could just point it out it
might be simple like oh you're mistaking
an a for a b
please because you're just like me
and that you are primarily a physicist
okay so if we look here this is
sorry if there's a double speak because
for whatever reason my cell phone has to
reply i don't hear it i just you're
single
okay entropy
is something like k d that's a boltzmann
constant
lawn and then this guy is
total number of states
okay so obviously i'm not saying
anything you don't know but obviously
this guy
looks like looks like this so then as
the total number of states goes up
entropy goes up that's why i'm having a
difficult time understanding
why is it when more is occurring entropy
decreases okay then let's look at it
this way
we started with all the bits in his
information system
random right we ordered the bits now we
have some meaning
now entropy goes down because we ordered
some bits we now have less randomness
so we order the bits we have a little
more complexity instead of all the bits
being random
we have ordered bits and those ordered
bits can be can mean things they could
be numbers or letters or they could
have some sort of meaning to them
they're symbols
they could be so when you order bits you
lower the entropy
high entropy is all the bits are random
so by
making a system more complicated more
complex
more meaningful more significant it can
do more things
you are you're looking at entropy as it
is defined
for heat problems
you're looking at thermodynamics there
but they're equivalent definitions
yeah you have to think of entropy in a
very fundamental way
okay fundamentally it's a measure of
disorder
okay so if you create order entropy gets
lowered so think of it in fundamental
terms don't
don't get lost in that equation that
equation was written for a very specific
purpose that had to do with
with entropy probably in um i don't know
what uh
adiabatic transfer of heat between
systems or something
so but but these two are equivalent
and then and obviously there's another
one that has to do with probability
but but they're all equivalent all the
different definitions of entropy
so when people say entropy measures
disorder
i it
well it technically measures the amount
of microstates
as you put heat into it you get more
disorder because everything is spinning
around more randomly right you're
randomizing the the molecules in the jar
right so you add heat and all the
molecules start zipping around
and then you take out heat and pretty
soon you get you take out enough heat to
get ice
now your molecules aren't zipping around
anymore you've got more order
you've got when we're talking about npr
i remember you said that
if what we have here is something like
this is physical matter reality right
physical matter reality it's some subset
of npr
let me know if this is too small yeah i
can see it
okay great it's pretty small but i can i
can see it
[Music]
look looks like n p m
r looks like this it's just i'm trying
to clarify please because
i have some questions about npr
afterwards and how to interact with it
and do you see it as if it's in front of
you like
like me and you are talking and and how
does one go about doing that
all good questions great great great
okay so we have npr
npmr and then we also have pmr i'll just
write that here
yeah okay okay and the claim is that
pmr is a subset of npm yeah right now
can npmr interact over here like
they're causally influenced within npmr
something can causally influence another
part of npmr
um or or only do you have to go to a
higher
np mr let's say
two this is npm r1 and only this guy can
influence here
no the things can be influenced within
within that npmr things can happen
decisions can be made choices can be
done that affect things
yes okay because then
like i'm overly done-ish so doesn't that
indicate that pmr is not a subset but
instead more like a
a target on a domain so here is npmr and
i'll tell you the reason why
and please forgive me if this is too
foolishly technical for no reason
but it's like there's a function let's
call it f and the domain is npmr
and then it goes to pmr and the reason
why i say these are separate
is because pmr can't influence you said
that you have to go out
only npmr can influence this guy
correct um can pmr influence without
npmr
no pmr is uh is a product
it's created by npmr yeah yeah right
right so then
the reason why i was having a bit of a
tricky time understanding this is
because if
pmr was simply a subset right here
it should be able to influence within
itself just like npmr can influence
within itself because it's a subset
unless there's something special about
this upset well well pmr does influence
within itself you know i mean we make
choices
you and i make choices we decided to
come here and have this talk you know
and that that may change
things you know now did that choice
occur in npmr or in pmr
oh at all all the your consciousness
is in npmr consciousness is not physical
consciousness is non-physical
information is non-physical
you are a non-physical consciousness
you're just playing
an avatar in a virtual reality game
but the problem you're having is that
these concepts are so
different from the basic world view
and and concepts that you know that most
people have particularly
technical people particularly physics
and science people that it just seems to
be
really hard to get your mind wrapped
around them
and and all the little problems that
pop up will disappear just once you get
that basic concept that we
are consciousness we are playing a
character
just like you would play an elf in world
of warcraft you're playing a character
that character
is your physical body that's the avatar
your consciousness now from that
avatar's
viewpoint the player is non-physical
and yeah i see you i see you're just
like just like a video game
and the computer is non-physical it is a
video game right it's a virtual reality
a video game
so you're the consciousness you are
non-physical
relative to the viewpoint inside of the
virtual reality which is your body
so your consciousness is a non-physical
thing but it's really who you are that
consciousness is a player
that consciousness is making all the
choices for that
avatar if the conscience doesn't give
that avatar it doesn't make any choices
the avatar just sits there i mean think
of your
your elf that you're playing if you
don't if you don't
you know hit a key or move a mouse you
don't give it any instructions it just
sits there and wobbles doesn't do
anything
well so all the choices all the memory
all the thoughts all the
all the processing goes on in
consciousness not in the brain
there really is no brain the
the brain is is not even rendered
unless somebody is opens a skull and has
to look at it
it's just a virtual reality right you
see yourself
as consciousness and you make all the
decisions you're making all the choices
and you are not in that virtual reality
so you are an npmr
you're non-physical to that that that
physical matter reality it's just a
virtual reality just like world of
warcraft it's a game
it's an energy reduction trainer what
happens
when there's brain damage which seems to
occur in physical matter reality
and exactly when there's brain damage
what happens is according
remember this virtual reality evolved
according to a rule set
right it's an evolved thing all right so
the way
the stuff is in that virtual reality is
because of the rule set
you know the rule set says that we can't
flap our arms and fly
so we can't do that it's the physics
chemistry biology that's the rule set
all right so now here you are and your
at your
avatar gets brain damage somebody hits
them in the head with an iron pipe
now the rule set says that that's going
to change the constraints on what that
system can do
same with your elf if your elf that
you're playing in world of warcraft
falls off a high cliff and hits the
rocks at the bottom
it's going to be damaged it's going to
lose hit points
it's going to have to you know go
someplace and rest or
eat or do something else it damages it
and now the player has to play with a
with constraints so you have brain
damage
you're the consciousness you now have to
play an avatar that has straight
constraints according to the rule set
okay
ruleset tells you what the constraints
are okay
so let's say i'm going to disembody this
and make some sort of visual metaphor
okay so your consciousness is up here
and somehow it's tapping into a video
game that's down here and it's playing
and
this is just like
now these two have a fight down here and
one of them is represented by you maybe
one is represented by someone else
okay that somehow affects what this guy
feels because the rule set says what
happens down here affects how you feel
am i correct so far is this or is this
off no
yeah the all the feelings are in the
consciousness
exactly now what makes you what makes
this consciousness
you because the way that i'm
understanding
an identity which is such a slippery
concept if you just
if you examine it it's not a
well-defined concept to begin with
but let's imagine it is which is
difficult
but what defines you is something like
you have a personality you have a
certain viewpoint you have
you have your choices and so on but if
those can be affected by what's physical
what's pmr
right with v with brain damage or
augmentations then that's affecting the
you which is up here which i meant yeah
it's just constraining
you so you have let's say you have brain
damage and now
you can't remember and you slur your
words
and you drag your left foot okay now
you're the consciousness
and i thought what's happened to your
avatar your avatar fell off a cliff and
hit his head on a rock
so now you have to play a character that
slurs its words
can't remember and whatever you you are
limited
by what the rule set says your avatar
can do
so you have a computer remember the
computer is computing this
now you're getting a data stream from
that computer yeah
and you're interpreting that data as
what's going on in that virtual reality
so now the computer says that
you can't get up and dance because
you're dragging your left foot you can't
go give a speech because you're slurring
your words
so if you say well i'd like to go give a
speech now
you can't get that the computer isn't
going to draw that in that reality
because the rule set says no can't do
that just like if you're playing an elf
and you'd say oh my elf's in a tight
situation
elf flap your arms and fly and what'll
happen
nothing it won't do that because the
rule set in world of warcraft
won't let your elf flap his arms and fly
so
you might want to do something as
consciousness but so you have
you know you have the constraints that
you have to work with as consciousness
now you're the consciousness you're
making the choices and you have all the
feelings part of
consciousness is the feeling part it's
the emotional part
so you're the one that feels the
emotions you're the one that feels the
pain you're the one that's
tongue feels too fat to get in your
mouth all that's part of
what you interpret the data to be
remember you are getting the data that
is all the sense data
that this avatar is getting okay so we
do world of warcraft it's just basically
visual and sound
okay when you do this virtual reality
it's visual sound and feeling it's touch
it's smell
it's everything okay i guess here's my
confusion
and i think this metaphor somewhat
rectifies it in world of warcraft
let's just choose that in world of
warcraft you have an avatar and you have
hit points and so on you have a certain
set of attributes
okay then what you're saying is it would
be a mistake
to identify the you as the avatar rather
than the player
is that true absolutely so then
what's left of the individual once
you've scrapped
the inclinations and the set of emotions
and the personality what's left why
would that be me why should i identify
with that
like i'm just being devil's advocate
well let me see if i
can answer your question this way so you
your your piece of consciousness
and you're going to log on to this this
avatar
and you're going to log on to that
avatar when that avatar is
very very young maybe even before it's
born
so you know it depends when there's
enough data coming in for you to
experience that's when you probably log
on
so you log on and because you don't come
with any history
all of your intellectual part doesn't
come with you the only thing that comes
with you
is the quality you've earned the amount
of entropy
you know that that you've reduced up to
this point so i call that quality of
consciousness
that comes with you and now you're
logged on just as quality of conscience
is logged onto this
avatar and all of the
sense data that you begin to get maybe
in utero maybe being born maybe
right afterwards all that sense data you
define that
as you because that's the only
intellectual information
that you've gotten in other words that's
it you didn't come with any memory like
okay i'm really sitting in my computer
and it's time for lunch i'm going to put
this game on hold
and go have a sandwich it's not like
that you're a hundred percent
evolved in involved in that player
and everything that that avatar has done
you feel like you have done because the
only data you're getting defining
reality is the data the computer's
sending you
describing what that avatar is sensing
now you have the emotions you have the
feelings the avatar is just some eye
candy
for you to look at so that you can see
the interactions and see what's going
on it's it's how you interpret the game
map and the players so you get that data
that's the data you have that's how you
interpret it
and you learn to interpret it as that
infant you know you learn to tell the
difference between uh you know
a house and your mother you just learn
that through your experience
so here you are this piece of
consciousness and you learn the
difference between mom and an apple and
dad and the car
and all these things as you grow up you
start building
language and vocabulary and ideas and
beliefs and things
so that's your world as consciousness
it's not like
you have something else going on you've
just this piece of consciousness is
wholly
100 logged on and you didn't come with
any
intellectual part now in my model i call
that
a free will awareness unit it's a subset
of the individuated unit of
consciousness
so the individual unit of conscious just
takes a subset of itself
and just its quality and logs on to this
this uh this game yeah
to get the data for that character okay
so
so what you are really is an individual
unit of consciousness
who has logged on a piece of itself you
put a partition
down to that piece of itself and you log
that on to this virtual reality game
you see that's kind of that's the way
you should kind of look at the structure
so yes let me see if i can explain back
to you so you know if i actually
understand it
okay i'm just imagining some orb okay
that's just the way my visual systems
work okay so i'm imagining an
orb over a landscape and this landscape
the orb can
shoot out one of its tendrils and then
it's odd then that's the equivalent of
logging on
okay and the orb represents
consciousness the orb represents me in
some way but this orb right now
doesn't have feelings because it's not
logged on i don't know if that's
actually true but in my metaphor okay so
right now has no sense data
it somehow puts out an arm goes into
this little baby
little baby boy who has certain
proclivities and then grows up and it
and it's fed that to its consciousness
that orb okay
then when this boy dies
in the physical world the body dies
let's say is the claim that the orb
persists and also that the orb was there
before the baby was born
or is it that the orb was created with
the baby somehow
okay it's it's all of the above it's a
little confusing but let me
try to lay it out for you yeah just
correct me where i'm okay
somewhat insensitive so we start with a
individuated unit of consciousness okay
and that's really
who you are you're a piece of conscious
you just
you know think of it as this big
conscious system
and it just takes a part of itself and
petitions that
often calls it you yeah okay that's
an iuoc it's just a piece of itself so
you can think of a
of an emulated uh you know
piece of this larger system so you're
just
a piece of the larger system and all
right so now that's you you're the
consciousness
okay now he finds out that you can
evolve
more readily if you log on to this game
because this is an entry reduction
trainer and what you're trying to do is
reduce your entropy
okay so because of that you take a piece
of yourself
now you partition off just a piece of
yourself that contains
your quality of consciousness and that
piece of yourself
now is the thing that's receiving the
data stream
and is logged onto the game and is
working the game
okay so it has an avatar and it's
experiencing
it's just a piece of myself though just
a piece of yourself
what are the other pieces doing in in
this example the other piece
is is basically going to be the
accumulation
function of all of your experiences
because the whole point
is to is to evolve and to do that
is as a as a iterative process
all of my experiences from past lives or
all of my lives
all of your experience from all of the
from all the avatars you've ever played
all the choices that you've ever made
all of that is kept and accumulated
because it's all part of this growing up
process
if you understand your history it's
easier to make sense of
you know what you're doing so it's it's
this community function so that's what
your your iuc is that function
so it takes a part of itself not the
memory of all those past
lives or anything else takes up just the
quality logs on
becomes you the little baby boy you go
through life
and that little baby boy gets old and
dies of old age and
now what happens as soon as he dies of
old age
he's no longer in the avatar anymore
avatar is dead
so the avatar you're not getting any
more sense data from the avatar since
data stopped
okay so that that consciousness that was
this
this uh free will awareness unit the
subset
of the iuoc it starts to
take that partition down it starts to
reintegrate with the individuated unit
of consciousness
life over so yes
that individuated unit of consciousness
is immortal
it lives on through many lifetimes just
because your elf dies
the player doesn't drop over dead you
know the player continues on
so now that uh but said instead of being
a player
where you just have all of you you know
you're there you're in your room you
know you have a refrigerator in the next
door and you're playing
and you can always put it on pause we're
not doing it that way we're going to
take a part of you
that's going to log on and stay with
that game period
from that point on it's just logged onto
that game and doesn't do anything else
and it starts
not with any memory of what it started
with but just with its quality
okay so okay so it's just a piece of you
all right now that you die that piece of
you now
the partition's taken down because it's
not logged on
no point logging onto a dead thing so
the petition's taking down that free
will awareness unit kind of re
becomes a part of the individuated unit
of consciousness and one more lifetime
of experience is there
for it to try to evolve from its
experience and then it begins
the individual unit of consciousness
starts to negotiate for another
another lifetime another chance to learn
things
and it repeats again it partitions off a
part of itself at its now new higher
quality of consciousness because you
were a good boy and you did a lot of
good things so now you leave the hole a
little higher
it goes back with that little higher
level quality of consciousness
and starts the thing all over again
starts to in you know
connects logs on to interesting baby
okay so that's the way the process works
so
you the consciousness that's making
choices is just a subset
of the of you you're i'd say okay iuc
okay so you're the cumulative
part yeah now when people say you should
have been one should abandon their ego
is that somewhat approximately like
saying don't
mistaken the avatar as the orb or
mistaken the avatar as the individuated
unit of consciousness
or is that different no abandoning your
ego
is a little is a little different thing
ego
their first consciousness is awareness
that makes choices
simple definition of consciousness it's
awareness that makes choices
all right now ego is awareness in the
service of fear
ego is about self it's self-focused
and that's because of fear so fear
really creates
ego it's awareness in the service of
fear
that's ego now given that most everybody
in our
in our world has a lot of fear then
everybody in our world has a lot of ego
so much so that when freud looked at
everybody in the world he said well
everybody's got ego and they seem to be
doing all right so it must be a good
thing
okay so it's not really a good thing
it's a dysfunctional thing but it's what
we're trying to outgrow and get rid of
we don't want to have our any of our
awareness in the service of fear
okay so that's so ego is
is that ego is is a
representation of your fear ego is the
thing
that tries that helps you whitewash over
wait wait sorry ego is a representation
of fear
there's ego is a product of fear let me
put it that way
it represents the fear in the sense that
what the ego does
is it tries to make you feel better
about the fear it whitewashes the fear
the fear says oh you know i feel
terribly inadequate
and the ego says oh i'm not inadequate
that person's just a you know just a
crud that person's really stupid
they just think i'm inadequate because
they're so stupid that's the ego
that tries to whitewash over the fear so
you don't have to deal with that fear
you blame it on somebody else oh i don't
get angry
george makes me angry could you feel
fear without an ego
and could you have an ego without fear
if you
didn't have any fear you wouldn't have
any ego
okay and if you can you have an ego
without having fear
sorry i think those are equivalent no
yeah you you can't let me restate it
let me restate it i'm wondering about
the implication arrow so
does fear always imply an ego
yes okay now does ego always imply a
fear
yes okay so then
i know you don't like when i do this but
to take it a bit mathematically though
it's how you it's yeah they're they're
equivalent but it doesn't mean they're
the same
right right does not mean isomorphic is
not the same right yeah
that's different so because you because
ego is a product of fear
then you're not going to have an ego if
you don't have any fear
and if you have an ego well then you
have must have fear because ego is a
product of fear
you say so they're different but they're
not equivalent
they're not the same thing one produces
the other so you can't have
you can't have something produced that
doesn't have the thing that produced it
wait well okay i need i mean
let's get to let's get to the npmr
experiences
because there were two extremely
interesting parts of the book not just
two
obviously but there are two that stood
out to me that i desperately want to
talk to you about
so one is your first experience where
you went in and
you had such uh transcendence from
transcendental meditation that you
almost fell off your chair
okay i don't believe in that time you
spoke to other beings but at some point
i believe when you were younger you
spoke to some beings and then when you
were older you recalled it and then you
were able to do it
some more okay now uh
like that's super super super super
interesting
because well the implications for that
now everything i'm saying if ever it
sounds like critiques
please i desperately want to believe
in i know you don't like belief but i
doesn't really work yeah i don't want
you to believe i want you
to experience it for yourself i
understand
it would be great if all of what you
were saying was absolutely true
and so if you see what i'm doing as
almost poking and prodding please it's
like
i want to believe and so i need to i
don't need i don't get great i don't
care about poking and priding poke and
prod
all you like feel free to ask the hard
drive but it's coming from it's coming
from a good place i just want you to
know that
okay i'm not trying to make you look
foolish in the least no that's not the
point i don't mind hard questions if you
want to say well how do you know you're
just not making all this up
oh yeah yeah okay so let's go let's get
to a little bit of fallibility i don't
mind
when it comes to the two part there's an
intellect and then there's an intuitive
part of you
now the intuitive part is notoriously
fallible
and airy yeah for most people that's not
its nature
it's just that way in most people well
we can
say that it is somewhat in nature only
because
well as far as we know animals don't
have much of an intellect and
when we were in our more tribal states
there was much more war and famine
and brutality let's say obviously we
magnify that because of our intellect
with nuclear weapons and so on
well let me make one statement about the
about what you said that maybe you'll
help clear things up
your intuition can be just as
accurate and just as reliable as your
intellect
yes just have to develop it okay in our
culture
we don't develop it we just develop our
intellect and we spend you know
20 or 30 years going through school and
graduate school and you know we go to
college with all this stuff
to develop our intellect we do nothing
to develop our intuition so our
intuition
is terribly undeveloped if we didn't go
to school
and develop our intellect that wouldn't
be working very well either we wouldn't
have much of an intellect
so we your intuition
can be as accurate and as reliable
as your int you know your intuition can
be as accurate and as reliable as your
intellect
it's just that we don't develop it
if we did develop it we could use it
as a as a very professional yeah and is
one of the claims the way that we
develop it is through
love because the way that i would
understand that we develop it at least
through my research
as unspecific as this sounds is through
truth and love
but love and truth are so tricky to
define but we have an intuitive notion
of them like we know when we're lying we
know when we're deceiving we know and
we're manipulating
you develop that intelligence yeah you
develop that intuitive space
a couple of there's a couple of things
that are required to develop it
and in the process of developing that
intuitive space
you often do evolve some and become a
little more loved so they're connected
but it's not that love you know really
develops the intuitive space it's like a
a product of developing that it
i think it comes with it because you
made an analogy between
love and the lowering of the entropy
sorry love is the lowered state of
entropy whereas the process of lowering
love is something different than love
yeah okay so this intuitive side
one you have to reduce the noise level
in your mind this intuitive state is a
mental thing
right so first you have to reduce the
noise that's what you learn when you
meditate you learn
to reduce the noise so you don't have
these
thoughts buzzing through your mind all
the time what am i going to do next what
about this i should read that other book
what's for dinner tonight you know do
psychedelics
also help with this or is that
completely different psychedelics are
basically a real bad idea at least if
you
use them more than once
more than once or twice they're a very
bad idea so i don't recommend
psychedelics
they give you an experience but an
experience
you can't grow up from an experience
it's it's what you it's what you make of
the experience it's the process of
having that experience of getting there
and coming back and so on it's the
it's the journey not just the experience
so having the experiences is
maybe a it may be a wow and it may be
something that
you feel like it's a you know a
life-changing event but it really
doesn't change much
it's it's how you integrate that
experience the context in which you have
the experience
and being shot up you know like a rocket
because you're taking a drug yeah
definitely big experience but
it's not really going to take you
anywhere significant is there nothing
salutary to say about
psychedelics because there are
experiences that people feel
and then they come back and it's
something like a 70 70
of people five years later so almost
permanent effect
a one standard deviation in the feelings
of openness and feelings of compassion
as self-reported and reported by their
family members so that's why
it seems like whether or not they're
experiencing something real
quote unquote it seems like it's as a
whole good
i'm not saying you're denigrating
experiences but why are you putting them
at a
second here i'm putting it this way
because
it's the same thing about the difference
between acting kind and being kind
okay so the experience is something that
your intellect
has it's your experience this is what
you
did this is what you said this is what
you saw okay
now that experience can be
amazing and can be life-changing but if
it doesn't
get from your intellect down into your
being level
down into your intuitive side then you
will just
it'll be a way you act but it won't
change who you
are that's the difference now
some people uh you know take drugs and
once they take a drug and they kind of
get that vision
and they see this bigger picture then
they start
searching they go to the internet and
what's going on has anybody else seen
things like that
and then they become seekers that's good
okay now that drug
event was a good thing in their life
because it pushed them in the right
direction
what's bad about drugs is if you take
that experience
and you don't make the effort and do the
work
to learn about it to internalize it to
grow up from it
then you want another one because that
one was kind of cool well let's do it
again and let's do it again
and you become convinced in your own
mind that you are much more spiritual
than you were and you should think big
thoughts and that you act better and so
on
and you may actually act a little better
but the point is are you growing up are
you changing yourself
is the real um what's the word uh
authentic you different than you were
before
and yeah a little example of this as far
as science goes is that when um
his name escapes me now he did research
pretty good research
with um dmt
strassman or something like that
strasberg straussman
anyway he did dmz research so he got a
bunch of people around and over a year
so he got these people gave him
psychology tests you know
interviewed them really got into their
minds and who they were and what they
were and attitudes and
then he'd give them some dmt and and in
a very controlled
situation they had experiences they
described these as life-changing
experiences they saw big pictures they
they learned and so on well after all
that was done
and each of them had had probably a
dozen or more
trips maybe twice that many i don't know
but when the research was done he waited
for
six months or a year or two i don't
remember maybe as much as five and he
got all the people back together again
and ran them through all those same
psychological tests and who they were
and what they thought and what their
attitudes were
you couldn't find any difference he said
for all the times he heard this has
changed my life
it didn't really seem to change
anybody's life
so most of that is perception of the
person who has seen those things and
feels smarter bigger and better and it
reminds me of a bunch of drunks sitting
around a table
all of whom feel brilliant and in one
night of
of uh imbibing they saw of all the
problems of the world and uh
you know in a in a perfect way go home
and the next morning can't really
remember what those solutions were
i think it's uh it's more of for most
people
it changes them at the intellectual
level
and it changes their perceptions but it
doesn't necessarily change
them now that's a generalization i'm not
saying that that is the way it is for
everybody
i'm just saying that typically people
who take drugs
tend to think that they are
different fundamentally when mostly they
didn't grow up much from it at all
for them it was like a roller coaster
ride a peak experience
but if it doesn't change you so that
experience has to get from the intellect
down into where you actually change who
you are
otherwise there's no growth can
experiences induce a change
without you having to try just because
you've experienced it for whatever
reason
like let's say neo coming out of the
matrix that i would imagine would
fundamentally change them
without trying it just shocks him into
change and then he no longer wants to be
in the matrix yeah well what it does
is it is it reorients his understanding
of what reality is
and understands an understanding of
what's important and what's not
you know it totally reorients his
reality so all the things he used to
believe
well now he realizes those things
weren't
so some there's some other different
reality here
and if he really takes that
in and says oh this is the way it is and
he sees it
and he's convinced that then yes it's
changed him so an experience
can change you at a deep level and some
people can have
transcendental you know awakenings and
experiences and it does change them
at a very deep level most people
not so much much if it takes if it comes
from drugs didn't get any worse
and when they hit bottom they begin to
think of you know
well what else can i do what else is
there i'm done i'm at the bottom i have
to stop contr
trying to control my reality i got to
just accept it
and once they start accepting and stop
controlling
oh suddenly they get better and better
and you know six months later they're a
whole new person
they've grown up they've transcended
this problem of needing to control
everything
and now they can let things go okay it's
a growing experience
so you can have experiences and come out
of them grown up more
than when you went into them but that's
because there was the context
the context of the journey of getting
there of the dissension of the pain
of the being there of giving up and then
when you give up
control you start to come back up the
other side
so within that context they can change
themselves but the context is
well i swallowed a drug and i had this
experience
and then i woke up the next day where's
the context where's the learning context
you see so most people that do that
have a harder time growing from it than
if they actually have a meaningful
journey to get there taking a drug is
not a meaningful
journey it's just wham there's the
experience oh now it's over
you feel bad you feel sick depending on
what kind of drug you take
and uh that's the end of it whereas if
you spend time
meditating clearing your mind getting
focused
being able to shut the intellect down
being able to con
to make connection to information that's
that's intuitive
well now that's the thing that's going
to take you years to do and a lot of
effort and work and you're going to work
on getting it more reliable and
understanding it
and when you get there you're a
different person but it's not just
because of the experience you had it's
because of the
all the things you learned along the way
it's the context in which that
experience
happened so without the context and
drugs doesn't have a contract
other than swallowing pills or drinking
a liquid and
that just doesn't help most people grow
up very much
but they feel more grown up because they
had this fantastic
experience they saw the world as it
really was
and okay they've seen that but now
how is that going to change who they are
for the most
the time it doesn't that doesn't mean it
can't it just means
most people that doesn't as far as i
know in the research for with
maps which studies psychedelics somewhat
assiduously the reports are that
people's families report them as being
and
something like a 70 i'm not advocating
for drugs so people who are listening
please don't take this
but something like 70 of the people have
self-reports that they're more spiritual
and open but you're like well
forget about self-report you can take
cannabis and say you drive better
because you're assessing yourself when
you're on
cannabis well the family reports too
yeah
in a way they would be because they come
back and
because they've had this big experience
they have a larger picture
they have this they have this larger
picture they see that
and intellectually they've gained
perspective
is there a reality to this larger
picture that's induced by the
psychedelics or
is it false and the true way to truly
see
let's say you have to go through years
of meditation are they opening the same
doors in other words or similar doors
no it's not false it's real they're
going into the
you know they're going to call it npmr
yeah they're going into the same
kind of mental space it's just mind it's
mine space it's not
you know it's not a special place it's
mind space when they take that drug then
they're
taking an adventure in mind space it's a
mental thing
and that's the same thing that you get
to when you meditate and do other things
it's just they're getting it without any
useful context i see i see
and when they come back they feel more
spiritual they feel more
relaxed maybe and more expansive and
they have these feelings
for a while and basically family could
say yeah they're
calmer now they're more uh sedate you
know they're not as
raucous or they're not as bad behaved
and that's probably true for a while but
it tends to wear off
it tends to wear off over time and
again if it just means that they're
acting better okay maybe they you know
it's maybe like the thing where you're
you know you're afraid of god so you act
better
maybe when they see this big picture and
they see reality and they kind of see
their place in it they go oh
i need to clean up my act i need to act
better but again
if it's acting the family would be
appreciated acting is like i say a
civilization
civilizing family would say oh great
he's acting better
but did he really get anything useful
out of it other than
he's acting better well acting better is
that much
being better is you know is that much
it's huge
compared to that compared to the acting
we are not our image
we are something else if one was simply
acting better would they feel more
tranquil
or would they feel the same no they
would probably feel
more tranquil even if they were simply
acting better
for the wrong reasons yeah they would
feel better because in their mind
they're saying
see i was so uptight and i'm tense and
i'm you know make other people tense
i'm just going to relax i'm just going
to be still
and i'll be quiet i won't talk so much
i'll listen more
well that's the intellect telling them
how it is they should be
so that's how they are
that's what they do and something comes
into contrary to that they push it
they push it away they bury it someplace
so yes they would act better
they'd feel better but what happens is
when you're acting
the real you comes out you see the real
you still in there
and when circumstances change to where
let's say
suddenly that person finds themselves in
a situation that
is very unpleasant well all that acting
goes to hell in the handbasket
that real person comes roaring out of
that situation
and oh well there's the same old person
we used to know
still in there mean as ever you see
do they come out permanently or they
just appear in that negative scenario
they probably appear in that scenario
and then they go back to acting
it's just that you know that acting
isn't deep so what's wrong with that is
that if we
zoom out to the npr picture the entropy
has not been lowered in your
model yeah right so what happens you
know that's like you have a bunch of
people who all live
in a nice community and they all get
along and things work out fine
you know yeah everything's hard
everybody's pressed hard everybody's
stressed
and then what happens uh you know a ride
takes place
and you'll find that people nice people
people you know who you'd think riot
sticks
riot takes place you know somebody bombs
something and pretty soon you have
nice people are running in and grabbing
tvs and running off with them
they're uh you know they're joining a
mob and you know throwing rocks through
windows perfectly nice people last week
you know they would go out of their way
to be helpful to some money but right
now
well you see that's not true and i
totally understand
that's not two different people it's the
same person one person has
has an image they're nice but underneath
of that
there's something a lot raw that's the
problem with
civilization in our civilization we're
nice and polite we've learned how to be
polite
we've been taught as children be polite
so we're all very polite but underneath
that is a
that's a very thin veneer of politeness
underneath that is the real person
and when the going gets tough that real
person comes out that politeness goes
away
and that's the real us that's what
happens when things go bad
in an extremely practical scenario let's
say you have a toddler
okay and you said what we do is we
reprimand them and say hey
please act in this manner and then they
don't understand the reasons why they
just know
i might get hit if i don't or i'll get
yelled at or scolded okay
what would be a more effective way of
raising
let's say a three-year-old to
six-year-old
you would have to treat them with
respect you'd have to see them as a
little person
deserving your respect and you have to
interact with them on their level where
they
are so if they're doing something that
is
really annoying or rude or you know not
not good
you'd have to stop them but rather than
just holler and stop that
see that's not that helpful right right
you'd have to get down on their level
and and uh
interact with them you're not going to
give them a lecture because at three or
four years old you know lectures
don't work you know they're not going to
do much but you'd have to pay it's just
as bad as scolding
yeah you'd have to pick them up yeah
you'd have to pick them up
or stop what they were doing maybe if
they were banging you know something
on a window glass and you'd have to say
no we don't do that
because you could break the glass so
it's not a good thing to do
and you explain to them not that you're
angry see as soon as you're angry stop
that well you know they
they kind of put up a wall to that so
you have to be
calm you have to really care about them
and so there's a little person in here
that really doesn't know
that they're being destructive so we
have to treat them
kindly but we have to tell them no you
cannot do that you might break something
and then we let them go they do it again
we tell them that again
and then if they say after the fifth
time we decide well we're going to have
to do something more than talk to them
so this time we make them
you know go back in their crib for you
know 15 minutes or
some other kind of thing or you just
hold them don't let them down
until they so it's difficult but you
have to do it with
caring and with love and at their level
you can't do it
with the idea that they need to learn
how to act like you act
you know they need to be adult they need
to be more adult and we just holler at
them and we use
fear to control them don't do that or
you get us banking don't do that or you
be in time out so we try to frighten
them
into doing what we want well using fear
to control them
is not a good way to bring them up you
bring them up with love and one day
they will realize oh my parents don't
want me to do that
i shouldn't do it because my parents are
pretty smart and they know
they know what's good because they trust
you because they've always gotten
support from you you know it's a it's a
different sort of thing so with real
little children
it's hard because they only can
understand so much
so you expect a lot of behave bad
behavior
is okay you gotta you gotta deal with
that don't give him toys it'll break
glass
see i'm running a simulation in my head
and i see oh like a simulation
is in simulation and i find it hard
to get to an answer as to why we should
act right
quote unquote without making a reference
to one's ego
which is what we're saying we should get
rid of or the fear we should get rid of
and the reason why is let's imagine
there's a three-year-old four-year-old
child and you say don't
break that glass but don't hit that
because the glass may break well why
should i care about the glass breaking
because it might fall on the ground well
why should i care about that someone
else has to pay for it and they also
might get hurt well why should i care
about that
eventually i would imagine in your model
but this is just me imagining
it would come down to don't do that
because that's ultimately bad for you as
well
sure they would learn they would learn
that it's part you know we're all here
but then to me that's that's an appeal
to an ego no because they're saying
don't do this because it's bad for you
no what what you would do is say that
we're all here together
and it is going to be bad for them but
that's not the the key point
it's that we all live here together we
all share this space
we all have to look out for each other
you know that's the thing
if you break that glass then you might
step in it and cut your foot and mom
might step in and cut her foot that cold
air would come in and we would be
uncomfortable bugs would come in and we
wouldn't like that
so it's going to be a problem for
everybody that lives here
and you know and it's going to be a
problem for you too so okay
but it's everybody's problem now you'd
have to have a kid that was more like
six or seven years old before they
understand that
if it's a three-year-old basically or a
two-year-old
what you do is you take the thing that
can break glass out of their hands
yeah because it's not an appropriate toy
for them right if they've got a hammer
they're not old enough to have a hammer
even okay so let's talk about this
we'll talk about a six-year-old or a
five-year-old incessantly asks why what
if they say so why
should i care about that it's bad for my
family
and it seems like it's obvious like i
should care but i'm i'm being a
particularly persnickety six-year-old no
you can
yes you would say well this is a problem
for everyone okay you leave your dirty
clothes all over the room then somebody
has to pick them up
and it's just extra chores that we need
to do
and if we're doing those tours we can't
be playing with you
or you know right that's why it comes
down to the ego no no it affects it's
not their ego
it's their caring that you're trying to
hit not their ego you're not trying to
make them
afraid and you're not getting to their
ego it's not that
oh that's good for me but it's i'm a
part of this thing it's good for all of
us it's good for me
and it's good for them they need to see
themselves as a part of a whole
not as just an individual now children
come into this world
very self-centered that's the nature of
being a child you are very small
you are very vulnerable and you are you
and then there's everything else out
there in that big world that scary world
so children are very self-centered and
we could
say that maturity is defined
as how much of that self-centeredness
you get rid of
so that's how you mature it's how you
grow up is by
reducing that self-centeredness well
that's reducing that
that ego so that's
you know you can have some people are 60
years old and they're still terribly
self-centered
you know that's they haven't grown up
much they're still
they're still acting like children so
children should be expected to be very
self-centered
that's natural for children and you
don't punish them for being
self-centered it's just who they are
you have to show them that they're part
of a bigger thing
they're part of a collective called a
family and they need to take
that into consideration and if that
family is working well together and the
family is working
then their life is going to be happier
but if they're you know if the family
isn't working together then their life
isn't going to be through well so it
does affect them
ah okay but they'll see themselves as
part of something bigger
it's not just about them so if i care
about the positive
that's not necessarily my ego but if i
care about the negative or fear that's
my ego
so for example if i care about i want to
be happy i would associate that with the
ego still because
you care about yourself in some way even
if it's i want to be happy that's not
that's not ego no ego is
awareness in the service of fear
remember consciousness is awareness that
makes choices
so awareness in the service of fear
that's ego if it's not in the service of
fear
that's not ego now awareness in the
service of love
that's what freud sort of roughly
defined as superego
okay it's about other it's it's not
just about self so you can say oh i'd
like to be better i'd like to
become love and now that's awareness in
the service of growing up
okay i like this because most of the
problems with me that i find and i'm
pretty sure that
many people have the same problem is
that some of these terms
the way they're used not you but the way
that they're used in general power lines
is equivocal and so when you use it you
mean something specific
but when other people use it for example
they synonymize ego with
self and so that's why i'm having a bit
i was having a bit of trouble
and i see this even in well hopefully
hopefully this podcast if you ever see
me getting into the meticulous
intricacies
the reason is that i try to be as
specific as possible first to
disentangle what's what's embroiled in
my head
but also because many other podcasts or
many other
interviewers or whatever it may be when
they talk they talk at a certain
layman level and i feel like plenty of
the
of truth is discarded in the simplicity
and even in physics like you know this
at least for me there's plenty that was
difficult to understand because it was
told to me incorrectly so
we're taught physics chronologically
newton laplace and so on and so on
but there's so much in physics it's
wonderful if you're actually taught it
in its specificity so for example
velocity is a more fundamental concept
than speed and speed is a more
fundamental concept than distance which
is the opposite of what we're told
but if the viewer or whoever's listening
understands a bit of differential
geometry
you would know that velocity doesn't
require a metric speed requires a metric
so you need more structure to get speed
and then you need something called
partition of unity to integrate over
speed to get distance
and that's interest is totally
interesting but it trips you up if you
don't
it trips you up at the later years of
physics something else is uh the wave
function
the wavefunction is not a function the
wavefunction is technically a smooth
section on a c
line bundle and you'll get into well i
got into plenty of trouble
thinking that it's a function because
then how are you supposed to do quantum
mechanics on a sphere
you have to have different open spaces
that you do yeah you have to
conceptualize it as a
as a section but anyway so hopefully i'm
kind of aware that all these things are
metaphors
there is no wave function they just say
wave function because they don't know
what else to say
physicists are mostly materialists and
they really don't like action at a
distance because
that's that's not materialistic you know
they they want
a trail from here to there of everything
that's why they generate
fields fields don't really exist you
know there are no fields
there's just information information
doesn't require
a field so
they will take a a they know that
okay we've got this particle and we
there's some
probability that it's going to manifest
someplace and they look at that
probability distribution
and they see how that works and then
they want to
make some kind of connection some kind
of
causal connection between the two and up
comes
a idea of a wave packet
and no nothing's waving it's a
probability wave
so it's just that they're probably in
this wave packet represents probability
all that's just metaphor it's stuff
they're making up
to allow them to create
a model in which to describe what's
going on
but particularly with quantum mechanics
when you try to get down into the
details of what is this wave function
it's just exactly what is this wave
function what's waving here what's the
function
you'll find it all falls apart because
there really isn't any such thing it's
just
a metaphor for the thing
that allows you to get from a to b what
you're calling a metaphor you mean
a model yeah okay it's just a model
something somebody
makes up you know all the things are
like that an electron
is a model it's a metaphor you know
we measure we say an electron is a
little
chunk of mass with a charge well that's
not an electron anymore that used to be
an electron before we understood better
now we know that electron is a point
with the attributes of mass and charge
see there's a difference so people who
measure let's say the original uh
was a milliken oil drop experiment back
in 1800s where they use a
you know two plates an electric field
oil drops they
decide that there's a charge on it and
they decide what the charge is you know
that's
e it's the charge of the electron well
what they measured wasn't an electron
they measured an effect
right they only measure effects and then
they make up a model
they make up a thing called an electro
let's call it an electron because we
believe in particles
so we'll make that an electron and it'll
have this charge and
to be a thing it has to have a little
chunk of mass well that doesn't work
quantum mechanics looks at electrons as
a chunk of mass with charge they can't
get anything right
they look at it as a point with
attributes of mass and charge
they can get the right answer so we find
out that there really
is no electron it's just a model
in order to explain the result
that they get so we make all sorts of
models and then the problem with that is
in the beginning people are aware that
these are just models
right things we make up in order to
have some way of you know of saying how
it
how it works so we make this model and
then we begin to believe it
rather than realize that it's just a
model and pretty some it becomes
dogma and of course electrons are little
chunks of math with charge everybody
knows that
and it becomes dogma and then it becomes
a blind spot because it's a belief
and now we can't understand things
because they don't act that way and all
that's just weird physics you know
that weird quantum mechanics so the
problem is that we don't realize that
much much of the stuff that we think of
as
facts are not facts they're models
they're theory they're somebody has
reached up and brought right out of the
clear blue
sky a reason why
this could be the the causal link
you know the causal thing that's
happening because we believe in
physical causality material causality
because we're materialists we need a
material cause for things
when actually all we really need is
information so we don't have to have a
field
we just have a calculation of what the
force is
at this point and at that point and some
other point
then okay a field can predict those
measurements
but predicting them isn't causing them
they're caused by information
they're caused by being part of the rule
set that's the way this place works
it's a different way of looking at
things but but you you'll see that when
you get into the details of physics
often you'll run into things that are
hard to understand and hard to explain
and that's because mostly they're models
and we're trying to make them into
little physical things
and they're not they're just models
to try to draw a materialistic
description of how does this get to that
how do we end up with this result so we
easily you know we can do math math
we we write down math and then we
interpret the math as something physical
well most scientists i would say at
least if you're a good scientist you
should be what's called an
instrumentalist
that is you don't confuse your model for
reality you just say that
predicts and it's falsifiable and it
seems like every time we do so and so we
get this result and that's
exactly what the equations say exactly
it doesn't mean
well obviously as you know there are
plenty of concepts that have been
overturned over and over
but it's not just just to defend science
in general
it's not just models like someone makes
it up they do make it up but it's not
made up in the same way that the fairy
a fairy is made up or it's made up it's
made up as an explanation
and usually the explanation is driven by
materialism and we need a material cause
does that mean that there is no science
of consciousness because if
one is to presume consciousness is
non-material but we've heard this term
i'm sure you've heard this term and i've
interviewed other people who
claim to be studying the science of
consciousness are you saying that there
cannot be a science of consciousness
because science is just of the material
world no there is a science of
consciousness what we're saying is that
science
should not be relegated
or exclusive to objective world
there's a lot more to our reality than
the objective world
and if you take say only the objective
world can be science
then that means that consciousness can't
be science because it's subjective it's
conscious it's in a mind it's subjective
obviously
but i would say that of course you can
have a science of consciousness that
science
is applying logic to problems it's
making models
that work models that will explain
things
and if you can make a model and if it
explains
all of your personal facts that are in
your you know in your experience
then that's a good model and if it
predicts other facts
and and gives you structure in which you
can hang your experience
then that's a valid model and it's
scientific because it's based on logic
and it's
you know it's understandable it's
repeatable it's
it's whatever so sure there's a science
of consciousness now
many physicists would deny that they
would say that physics
chemistry and biology are the only
sciences there are and everything else
is soft science like have you heard of
daniel dennett
i mean obviously you've heard of daniel
have you read daniel dennis book
consciousness explained no i have not
read it
okay i was gonna ask your opinion on it
let's change gears
okay and go back to you having some
experiences with
npmr or mind space individuals i don't
know what else to call them
yeah just just the uh experience within
the larger consciousness system this
physical reality
just being one one subset
of that okay actually let's go back to
you debugging some code
are you suggesting that you were able to
see the code as if out of body
or are you suggesting that your memory
was much better than you thought and you
were able to see the code in your own
brain
sitting there in the chair because
you're in a deeply hypnotic meditative
state like which one are you suggesting
okay
then it's a little bit it's like the
second but more
so yes i could see the code and it would
it was scrolling by me just like i had a
uh you know a printout you know you get
printouts
and it was almost like it was on a
scroll and it was just going by and i
was seeing the live dakota they went by
and
and one would go by and be red and i'd
stop it and rewind
and go up and look at that and i just
look at that line of code
and because i wrote all the code i knew
exactly what each line represented and
where it was
and i say really that's the problem okay
and that's a problem now i might not
know what the problem was
but that line of code had a problem in
it so i'd go up there and i'd look at
that line
and if i couldn't find the problem i'd
check
i'd re-punch the card and seeing if the
same thing re-punched work because
perhaps it was
an error in printing there was an error
in the punching
yeah so i'd realize that and when i went
up and checked those lines
sure enough they all you know it worked
it worked perfectly all the ones that
were read
had errors in them so it is obviously
memory in the sense that i
could see all those lines i was very
familiar with them but it was more than
just memory because i was getting it and
it was scrolling
and if you'd asked me tell me what line
is above that one
i wouldn't have been able to tell you
what line was above that one you know
out of my memory
i couldn't have i couldn't have said
that i didn't have the whole you know
shoot i had like 4 000 cards i didn't
haul i didn't have any of that memorized
but they were scrolling by in the right
order and i could see them so you could
say well that was somewhere deep in your
you know in your subconscious and you
pulled that back up but
i find that the kind of a wild you know
conjecture no i'm not suggesting that at
all i'm actually
trying to visualize it so when you see
it are you seeing it
with a with a black background and it's
just the cards
are you seeing it as if you're not
pretty much a black background and just
just the lines going by and did you go
in with the intention
of wanting to debug or was that just the
experience that came to me it was a
fortuis
combination i was in i was meditating
and i also was thinking
about my code you know that is when you
when you work on something like
debugging
and it takes you you know you're working
on it over weeks
and you have this thing and you're
always constantly thinking what is the
what is the problem here you know what
isn't working
and i had that i was in a meditation and
i had that thought come up because
that's what and you also mentioned that
transcendental is much better
for people who have chaotic minds
because they don't have to stop
thinking in the same way that
mindfulness
wants to yeah they they
they're thinking but they're thinking
nonsense right they're thinking stuff
that's non-operable
you know something you can't operate on
something that the intellect can't do
anything with
you know just a meaningless sound yes
yes so that's right that's the thing so
you know if you're if your mantra was
a ham sandwich yes then that wouldn't
work because
how'd you know mine that wouldn't work
because you might get hungry or you
might
think that's why it's not working for me
okay okay so when i'm doing mine
sometimes i put my fingers together
sometimes i don't
does that matter because i see people
who traditionally they interlock certain
digits
right does it matter not really
does can it can it be a value
yes it can there's a lot of things
you know you're familiar with the
placebo effect
okay so if you think you're likely to
get better you
will get better if you think this is
going to help you
it possibly can help you and make it
work better
just because it makes your attitude more
positive toward it your intent becomes a
more positive intent toward the outcome
which actually then changes the outcome
yes it can be effective but it isn't
anything fundamental and you can open
this
circuit or close that circuit and it'll
feel a little different
you're just feeling in your body or you
can be lying there and you can touch
your feet together or pull them apart or
put your hands on your
on your legs or put your hands up here
and you can feel
a little different oh this feels
different the energy seems to flow
differently well that energy flowing
differently
is is this metaphorical your
your your differences are things that
you're looking for a difference and
you're finding one
you often look for the you often find
the things you're looking for
okay because you tend to
manifest them you create the stuff
you're looking for so if you could say
well
i'm going to test this and see how this
works and you'll find a little
difference there
you can turn it into a tool oh whenever
i put my fingers together like this i'll
be able to meditate real easily
now it becomes a tool and it's a thing
you can use to help
calm your mind so yes it works but no
it's not fundamental
it's not about the body the body's just
an avatar
the body is a picture on a screen he
mentioned that doing it lying down is
not as effective as sitting
and i'm wondering why is that the case
oh well most of the time i don't know
that i said that but i probably did
i would say it because for most people
lying down
ends up falling asleep or losing
consciousness whereas sitting up is much
harder
to do that so often people have a
problem with they start to meditate and
then they end up falling asleep
if you sit up that's less likely to
happen for you who's
an expert in this can you get to a state
where you visit mind space or
npmr with lying down and doing your
mantra
or without even doing your mantra i can
get there in
less than a tenth of a second while i'm
doing anything
that's because you practice it for so
long yeah sure
it's just uh getting into these other
spaces is just shifting your intent to
another data stream
how long does it take you to go from uh
you know the sims to world of warcraft
you can see how old my metaphors are
right
but you know how long do you play video
games have you played them before no
i don't play them when video games were
a thing and i was young enough to have
the time to do it
um you know there were no computers the
world is a computer anyway so
yeah so i uh by the time they came
around even the very crude ones
you know i was uh you know in my 40s and
50s and i watched my children play them
so i have spent some time looking over
their shoulder because i'm interested in
how does this work
you know what's the graphics like you
know what are the rules and
it interests me so i watched my kids
playing them but
i've never really spent much time
playing i've always had too many other
things
on my plate to do that we're a higher
priority
what's the relationship between your
theory and non-dualism
well there is a relationship in that
non-dualism
basically ends up with the idea that
we're all one right it's not to us it
could not us and them
we're all one thing and mine basically
says
we're all pieces of consciousness we're
all pieces of the
larger consciousness system now you can
think of a piece of consciousness and it
partitions off a little piece of memory
and and processing power and whatever
and ah there's an iuc and it
partitions off a piece of that no
there's a free will awareness unit
but it's all just within this larger
consciousness system
non-duality basically comes to the we're
all one and so do i we're all
we're all one thing which is
consciousness
we all have the same purpose which is to
evolve
it's uh yeah so in that sense we're the
same but i think some of the
non-dualists also go off onto other
other side issues that i don't i just
see that yeah as far as i know there are
five different forms of non-dualism
so what you're saying is i think modeism
which is that we all belong to the same
vellum the same underlying material
and then there's another that has to do
advaita i believe that says subject and
object are the same
and then there's non-negation which says
up down left right good evil they're all
the same
i don't think that one is what you're
saying because you do say
there needs to be a difference in order
for there to be information because you
can't have all zeros
you can't have all ones right there's no
better exactly right so there has to be
some difference so then it can't be that
one
and then advaya might be something like
the absolute and relative truths of
buddhism are one and the same
now that one you're not saying anything
about buddhism so obviously that one
doesn't count
but you did say something in the opening
when we were speaking which is that
my big toe you said it's my big toe
because it's about
my subjective understanding of the truth
and then that made me
question is truth subjective or is truth
objective
in your model ah truth is something that
um
that's a good that's a good question the
uh
yeah i have a couple of things that i
say a lot and one of them is
that uh you must always remain skeptical
okay it's it's you must be open-minded
and skeptical
both at the same time and the other
thing i say if it's not your experience
it's not your truth
so there are things like your truth
right
that's your truth yeah meaning
subjective
everything it turns out is subjective
there really is no
objective world everything is subjective
now here's
why that is but the but the what we call
the objective world
is just that part of the subjective
world that has very
small um
error bars is it's it's defined it has
very little uncertainty let me put it
that way
so everything is subjective you think
that it's that this
you know say a brick take a brick and a
brick is an objective thing
all right but it is only in a
only within the within the idea that
that brick
exists with a right has a certain volume
certain length width height but it
doesn't really
if you try to measure that you will find
that
there's always a plus or minus on it
there's always measurement error
nobody really knows exactly what its
volume is nobody knows exactly what its
length height
you know and exactly what its weight is
all those things fluctuate
from second to second so it's really
all those physical attributes of that
brick
are really in motion a brick is not
really any of those things what we call
a brick
is the average of those things it's
about this long about this high about
this weight
see so a brick is really subjective and
as much as if you had 10 people measure
it you'd get 10 different answers
because each one would get to a certain
point and they're measuring couldn't
measure it any more than that
besides the brick is always in flux
atoms are always leaving or molecules
are always leaving and
other things are always coming in it's
always in flux so
but the error bars you know a brick plus
or minus
is very very small so the uncertainty in
that brick is really really small
and but it's still subjective we cannot
make it
precise so in the world of everything
being
subjective those things that have very
very small uncertainty
is what we call the objective world
those things that have more uncertainty
like you know what is justice what's
truth
see they have a lot of uncertainty well
then we call those
subjective because the mind is
subjective
and we look at this outside world and it
has very little uncertainty about where
it is and how much it weighs and where
it's located and
what it can do because that is a little
small uncertainty about it
so everything is really subjective in
that different people would get
different answers
but if it has a very small uncertainty
it approximates being objective so it's
approximately
objective to a very good approximation
you see so that's the way it is so yes
you can have
subjective science subjective states
things that are reproducible
explanations that
are consistent and logical and accurate
over in the in the stuff with high
uncertainty too
but that on the uncertainty is a part of
them
you know they are uncertain so you have
to say that over here in the subjective
world you got to deal with more
uncertainty
it's not that everything is flim-flam
over there it's that you have to realize
that there's
uncertainties about things and a lot of
that uncertainty comes from the fact
that we have a very
untrained undeveloped
intuitive side and we're lousy with with
our intuition because of that our minds
are
jumping everywhere we can't focus uh we
have all these beliefs
which folk you know which change what it
is we can the data that we can accept we
get data that's
not con you know not within our beliefs
and we just
throw it away we refuse it we won't even
look at it
conscious system won't even register it
no that's that was noise
skip it because it's not with our belief
so in that world you can also be
scientific but you have to take
probability into account
because there's lots of of uh
uh uncertainty whereas with the brick
you don't have
to take probability into account it's a
brick
you know i don't care if it's a
thousandth of a millimeter
longer or fatter or lumpy or whatever
doesn't make any difference
so that's the difference in the world so
the science can apply everywhere
it can apply where there's very small
uncertainties and where there's large
uncertainties
science is just basically logic that
explains
facts that's what science is so if i can
give you
logic that explains why you feel the way
you feel and why you get angry
and it explains that with a model and
you look at it and you say well yeah
okay i got that stuff but i got that and
sure enough that's the result
there's anger and it it tells you about
what's inside your mind then that's a
good model if you look at my model and
it doesn't explain
your experience then it's not a good
model or you just don't understand it
you know one of the other but in either
case it's not useful so
you know throw it out so that's the idea
so
all of reality is just one thing and
that's
why you can have one overarching
understanding that covers all of it
thomas it's been a pleasure
i know you got to go or your wife is
going to kill you is it all right if i
just ask you there's a couple audience
questions you can just bang him out yeah
okay
it's hard for me to bang anything out as
you've as you've discovered but
uh go ahead okay someone said so excited
this should be a fun interview
one thing i'd like to ask tom about is
spiritual determinism classical
determinism comes from a belief that
matter
is fundamental physicalism and so on and
it's held by mainstream science however
recent quantum phys
let me read this through because this is
a bit wordy okay i'm gonna have to skip
that one because it's gonna take me
quite some time just to read it
what's just can you assume can you just
without all the explanations okay
let me just read it on my own and then
i'll sum it up because quite a bit
you can just define spiritual
determinism i don't know what
i don't know what spiritual determinism
is that's okay okay
whatever common belief in mainstream
science is that it's physicalism i think
it means materialism look physicalism is
materialism with fundamental laws
okay however recent quantum physics
refute this dogmatic belief on the other
hand
spiritual non-duality teachers start
with the opposite assumption that
consciousness is fundamental
yet they seem to claim that life is
predetermined
this claim is based on the teachings of
the highly respected masters such as
ramana maharshi
so and so on and many others for example
ramesh was known for his statement life
is like a scripted movie that's already
been completed
yeah it's in the can yeah i disagree
with all of that that is not the case
um their determinism is a
dead idea and i i would say
evolution is open-ended evolution
is choice choice making and the results
either evolve and go forward or they you
know they don't
they don't work out and they disappear
so it's always open-ended
and we are evolving toward lowering
entropy and you
never actually get to zero entropy
you're always working on it and as soon
as you stop
working on lowering your entropy your
entropy starts to increase
so there's always something to do so
no it's there is no determinism in this
and i think where that comes from
why these these gurus say that is
because
in order in our culture these days and
that's everywhere
that if you conflict directly
with science you're wrong
so these are they want to be accepted by
mainstream science
they want the cake they need to they
want to be accepted by
mainstream thought mainstream attitudes
not just science
science isn't going to go you know
except their religion but
just people when they say this thing
about determinism that's oh yeah okay
einstein
you know and his relativity and his
light cone and all that kind of stuff
you have time
you know the future in the past and all
exists at once and so on
yada yada so that has been publicized so
much because it's such a wowzy kind of
thing
that they have to meet that or they're
wrong and okay your your you know your
religion or whatever you got conflicts
with science science says it's not that
way
so i think that's why these guys end up
with that because they're trying to be
right you know they're trying to be on
the right side of science
but it's just not that way that math is
just being interpreted
wrong it doesn't mean that it's that's
how they're interpreting it
math is not the physical world math is
trying to be a description but you have
math and then you interpret it to be
a model of the physical world but these
interpretations can be wrong
you know they don't necessarily mean
that
it's just the interpretation people give
to it
that the past and the future and the
present are all happening at the same
time
is just the logical
doesn't make any sense and to say oh
yeah but that's what the equations say
no they're misinterpreting the equations
technically don't say that
because they don't even with classical
mecha sorry if yes classical mechanics
nicholas jessen who's a professor of
physics he makes a great argument that
you can't actually say that classical
mechanics is deterministic
because according to our evidence we
don't know past the error bar
and so it could be a finite amount of
digits
and then as soon as you have a finite
amount of digits you can have
indeterminacy
and then in addition to that science
presupposes free will on the part of the
practitioner otherwise you have
correlations and then all your
scientific experiments are not
i agree with all of that he's a huge
proponent of free will
although it's funny because he dislikes
god and virtually all spirituality as
far as i could tell
but he's a huge proponent of free will
and usually those don't go hand in hand
usually it's the opposite no usually
it's the other way around and he also
made a great argument that if real
numbers were real
real he said real numbers should be
called imaginary numbers because they
have infinite precision
and if real numbers were real we should
have black holes all around us because
each particle is carrying around an
infinite amount of information
and infinite and information has a
relationship to energy yeah right
yeah he's just poking little logical
holes and and you know this
these beliefs that physicists have okay
last
question this one's fairly easy for you
to answer says
you have stated that your model assumes
two things consciousness and evolution
however if objective science is to
explain if the objective of science is
to explain more with less
wouldn't the final simplest step be to
explain everything with nothing
rather than to explain everything with
consciousness so why would something as
seemingly complex as consciousness be
more fundamental than
nothing as the true foundation okay
that's easy to answer
nothing doesn't take you any place you
know it's like um
you can answer every question with god
does it
why is it raining today oh god does it
you know why
uh you know why did my car
you know stop god does it everything so
there's just one answer
for everything god does it all right
well what's wrong with that
what's it's not anything logically
wrong with that in the sense that you
could say that
there's an assumption god exists and god
does everything right that's the
assumption but given that assumption
then
that's logical god does everything but
what's wrong with that little piece of
logic
is that it doesn't go anywhere it
doesn't tell you anything
it doesn't explain anything it doesn't
give you any insight
it doesn't help you understand you see
it's a it's like the you know the
the null set okay then i have a better
theory
it's all it's almost useless in a better
theory it's just god statement
god did everything and you're not meant
to understand
now well it's the same thing okay so
what does that help me
do you're not meant to you're not meant
to be i'm not meant to understand so
it's not useful you see it doesn't have
anything
it doesn't have any function yeah it's
not meant to be useful but see people
like things that like meaning they like
to understand they like to be able to
predict
they like to be able to say well you
know if i do this and then that and that
this is going to happen
they'd like to be able to find reasons
for things
explanations um what do we call it the
um you know
consequences all all of that kind of
stuff is important
to people to understand the reality why
do you feel the way you do
why does this happen why does that
happen you know why is the sky blue
all these things you know well god made
it blue well that doesn't tell you
anything you know if you understand
about
light scattering and the wavelength of
the light and the particle sizes that
are there
then you can oh that makes sense okay
that's you know why we have seasons uh
you know why it gets from light to dark
you know all these things help
us understand our world better and
help us make better choices as here we
are to make choices and if we can't make
any choices because we don't know
anything
then everything's random and nothing has
any purpose or any point
so the reason that that is not a good
answer isn't that it's necessarily
illogical
god does it and you're not supposed to
know then that's a
assumption and it but it goes nowhere
it offers nothing it just leaves you
empty whereas
a solution that actually gives you a
model here's how reality works oh you're
miserable and unhappy well here's how
here's where happiness comes from here's
how it works
here's how you end up with that you see
oh you know
the sky's blue well here's here's why
that sky's blue
it helps you it helps you create
technology
it helps you build things you know we
have internets we can do this kind of
communication that we're doing
because we've made models of things
models and the models work so it helps
give us more possibilities
more possibilities are on our way to
better evolution so that's why that
simple answer is not a better answer is
because it doesn't deliver anything
significant
i got through only half of one page
so we'll have to save the rest for next
time but i do recall you saying that you
were able to look at a photograph and
see auras so you could see auras in
person at least at one point or if your
intention was correct
and then someone showed you a photograph
and you were able to see auras now does
that mean that the auras were captured
with photons
and then can you see over zoom can you
see auras over movies yeah sure
doesn't no they're not captured with the
film or anything else like it not have
anything to do with that all it has to
do with is intent
it's all information so that information
is available
in an intuitive space so all i have to
do is have the intent
and i have to give it the output format
well i i want
the the colors in the aura to
represent this that or the other thing i
make up an output format i can make up
any output format i want
and then i query the database and i get
the information
and if i want the information in terms
of a colored picture
and i tell the system what colors i want
to mean what then that's how i get the
information
so it's just that there that's what i
said we have all this information out
there on the intuitive side
that is available to us and
the reason we have all that information
out there is i can explain is it's
necessary
to for the for the rendering engine to
render the virtual reality
it needs some databases to help it do
that on the fly
so these databases become that it needs
to render
become our source of information and
you can just get that so it's not that
there was anything in the picture at all
has nothing to do with that
it just has it my mind has an intention
the intention collects the data
i get the data and my output format is
around that person i see
some kind of colored thing there is no
aura there's only information
are you able to get information from the
mind space world
that is more rigorous so for example
something i was going to ask you about
quantum field theory was
how because it's a small tone
unification that i'm interested
the second quantization in quantum field
theory is not rigorously defined same
with the path integral
so i was wondering can you query the
database and find out
how to rigorously define them or does it
not work like that
it probably wouldn't work like that
it might if you really understood it
well enough to
to see the big picture what was going on
then it might work like that because
what you might learn is that neither one
of them's right the whole idea
the whole the whole structure is wrong
minded
right right right but just like
newtonian gravity is a lower case limit
of
general relativity there may be some
deeper theory that can produce it and
then from that you can get the rigorous
foundation
yeah so the whole thing that you're
asking about though what i'm saying
might just be wrong
so you're asking the wrong question it's
like
you know what kind of tutus do flying
elephants wear
you know and you try to get that from
the database well there are no flying
elephants
you're you're asking something that
doesn't really
exist okay so i would see that would
probably be what you get sometimes but
let's say that's not the case let's say
it does exist and it is fundamental
could you get information like that yes
you could get information like that you
could get
only as much though as that you can
understand
okay so you have to be real close to the
understanding
to make sense of the information you get
this sounds just like
you know in the matrix one of the lines
that was the best was we can't see past
the choices we don't understand
exactly that line that line like it
makes me
it makes me want to cry i cried at the
original matrix
i watched it like about a week ago maybe
i was prepping for this interview
unconsciously
i watched it and i cried like four times
during it and not when people died but
there's some lines that are so
profound yeah well look at it what
happens if you take a
you know a cell phone to some little
tribe in the amazon jungle that's never
seen any technology
and you say okay here's a cell phone and
here's the schematics
and here's the dial here's here's the
you know the write-up that explains
everything in that cell phone
well what are they going to do with it
nothing
maybe they burn the paper to start fires
you know what are they going to do
with it well that one might be a bad
example because they gave some ipads to
people who have never seen ipads before
didn't even give them instructions and
then they were turning it on and
installing apps within a week
yeah so that i understand what you're
saying but that's learning
yeah they can learn and that's just a
trial and error and see what happens
but something like a cell phones are
going to acquire you know uh uh
integrated integrated processing units
and
lots of other things you know which yeah
which like imagine
yeah it's not something you're gonna do
just by pushing buttons and seeing what
happens
you can't get there that way so unless
they understood how to make a cell phone
almost
and this would give them just the last
piece they need okay
then it would work but if you take if
you're ignorant
of the answer and you get the answer you
won't understand it
so it only works in the fact that you
are just that far away from it
you've kind of got the general idea and
you just need some
inspiration to so it can put you one
step ahead
it can put you one or two steps in yeah
but it's not that's it it's not going to
give you the whole thing because
and even if it did you wouldn't have the
context to make sense of it no you
wouldn't make any sense of it so you
know maybe we are being thrown
and we just aren't understanding the
science we've got we got
lots of i mean look at this you know the
the insights that suddenly come to
people you know einstein writing on his
beam of light
or whatever and you'll see that a lot of
people
both artists and scientists get their
inspiration
from the non-physical intuitively oh
that's the solution you know it just
comes to them not when they're trying to
get it but
when they forget about it and relax and
think of something else and then
bang they get it from intuitive space
but it's only
got to be a half step beyond where they
where they are
otherwise they'll get it and it won't
make any sense and that didn't mean
anything you know so
there's a line from the new testament
which also you can ponder for
like ages makes me weepy it says jesus
said
the kingdom of god lies before you but
men do not see it
yeah sure geez man that's that's that's
powerful
yeah that is the way it is i mean it's
all simple
it's this virtu once you get the idea of
virtual reality and everything's
information
it just reduces almost all the
complexity
not only in science but just in everyday
life reduces
to really really a few simple ideas
that are very powerful and everything
makes sense it is all right in front of
you
you just don't see it because you're not
thinking
right you know your perspective isn't
right
thank you so much man you've pushed me
you pushed my car which is
the engine hasn't been working you
pushed it on the on-ramp i got it now
start it and i gotta
start driving i might go backward and
i'm hopefully i can go forward
well when you get reading the book and
you have issues with it think about the
thing
think about the idea that it's a virtual
reality that we're in a game we are
really consciousness
and and we're just playing this avatar
and
that will sometimes give you the
perspective that's necessary to see
the bigger picture because as soon as
you start with the physical
and it has to you know fall into a
materialistic
uh you know belief system then nothing
will work it'll all fall apart
we can do this again once you've had
plenty of time to digest that and
maybe finish the books and maybe even
for the second time you know and your
questions
your questions are going to get smaller
and smaller they're going to get bigger
and bigger for a while and then as you
understand it they're going to get
smaller and smaller
so um and if the people who are
listening
you have any questions please leave them
in the comments below if you want us if
you desperately wanted me to talk to
thomas again please let us know as well
okay song kurt
you